Das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
EitherCodeTV oder youbitar or contact seuWorkman.
Hallo Leute.
Teams hat wieder rumgestellt.
ExtremePainsChamp 1
Wir müssen uns heute mit einem etwas, Moment, bevor ich, bevor ich was sage ich ein Knoten mal kurz das Headset.
So, jetzt Headset entknotet.
So, auf geht's. Also, was wollte ich denn sagen?
Ja, wir müssen uns heute leider mit einem etwas unliebsamen Thema für mich beschäftigen und zwar Monitoring bzw. mal was ausprobieren.
Und zwar, ich habe bei mir daheim ja mittlerweile der Zappix. Ich sage euch, ich bin auch nicht wirklich scharf drauf, aber ich habe mir jetzt lange Zeit Gedanken gemacht.
Ich glaube für meine Lösung oder für das, was ich hier daheim habe, dürfte es die beste Lösung sein.
Also, ich habe hier daheim mittlerweile, also wenn ich im, ich schaue mal, ich sage es euch ganz aktuell.
Ich gucke mal kurz in meinen Router und sage euch, wie viele Geräte im DHCP Server drin stehen.
Das ist jetzt zwar nicht so richtig repräsentativ, weil beispielsweise mein Desktop und ein paar andere Klicks haben feste IPs, aber nur mal so, nur mal so ungefähr.
Also im DHCP Server Leases sind, also aktive Leases im DHCP Server sind, CheckMk habe ich mir auch angeguckt, das hat mir aber auch nicht so wirklich gefallen.
Ich kann dir aber gar nicht mehr aus dem Kopf sagen, was ist schon ein paar Tage her.
Also ich habe 73 Kisten im DHCP Server aktuell, die müssen natürlich nicht alle überwacht werden, aber ich nehme garantiert nicht PRTG, weil das ist Windows Only.
Es sei denn, das gibt es mittlerweile auch für Linux, ich zweifle es aber.
Da habe ich kein, nein kein Promisius. Wenn man das so schreibt, sieht es nochmal extra bescheuert aus.
Ja, also aktuell habe ich ja sowas hier am Start, guckt, ich zeige es euch nochmal kurz.
Ich habe sowas, was für ein Heimgebrauch, ganz, oh, Status Page vielleicht?
Ja, also ich habe solche, ich habe solche Dinger hier bei mir zum Beispiel drinne.
Also aktuell habe ich Partially Decreated Service, Monkeys. Aktuell habe ich sowas hier daheim.
Da ist dann drinne, so die Kameras sind drinne, der Raspberry Pi im Keller, ob der MQTT Server noch funktioniert.
Ja gut, das Unify Zeug ist down, warum wisst ihr, da kann irgendwas nicht stimmen.
Observium ist eher was für Netzwerkgeräte mit SNMP und sowas.
So, also warum auch immer das 100% ist, ergibt jetzt wenig Sinn, aber das Unify Zeug ist weg.
100% Downtime, ja, scheint so. Die Steckdose im Bad habe ich gerade abgestöpselt, ja.
Also so Sachen stehen da drinne, das ist nicht so umfangreich, wie ich es gerne hätte.
Und so ein paar Sachen sind mir da zu, wie soll ich sagen, zu rudimentär, ja.
Du kannst zum Beispiel nichts einsammeln, also über Uptime Kuma kannst du wunderbar monitoren.
Antwortet ein HTTP Server, pingt das Server oder sowas, das reicht in 90% der Fällen.
Aber gerade beispielsweise bei der Kiste für die Fernsehaufnahmen will ich checken, wie ist der Festplattenverlauf.
Und mich im Zweifelsfall auch warnen, wenn der unter 15% geht.
Hast du aktuell die Ruckus-Dinger aktiv? Ja, habe ich. Habe ich. Habe ich.
Ja, ach ja, bei der Gelegenheit wollte ich gerade mal gucken, ob es auf Ebay noch welche gibt.
Gibt es vielleicht sogar R710, weil im Zweiten, ich hätte insofern den Zweiten noch ganz gerne,
weil ich habe es jetzt so machen müssen, ich habe meinen Access Point unten im Wohnzimmer auf den Schrank gestellt.
Bedeutet eigentlich deine Domain, das bedeutet gar nichts.
Ich habe, also ja doch, weil ich sagen wollte, das hat keine großartig tiefere Bedeutung.
Das Punkt Haus ist, weil ich mir mal eine Domain für Heimautomatisierung gemacht habe.
Und wie ich auf, im Maul, weil die Katze im Maul macht.
Das ist total bescheuerte Domain. Also quasi Katzenhaus oder so.
Könnte man das nicht eigentlich, im Prinzip sowas wie Katzenhaus, ja, konnte ich mir gut merken.
Maupunkt Haus ist ansonsten aber keinen tieferen Sinn.
Was ist an der Domain denn jetzt? Also bei mir ist vieles Boomer.
Aber ich glaube, die meisten Boomer, die haben keine Domain für ihre Heimautomatisierung.
Oder was meint ihr?
Wie häufig kommt es vor, dass Boomer Heimautomatisierung mit eigenen Domain haben?
So, ich wollte mal kurz was gucken, ob es da vielleicht noch welche gibt.
Für Teile. Wie für Teile?
Was soll denn das? Das kannst du bloß vergessen.
Das Problem ist, Alter, die Einfuhrabgaben sind unglaublich teuer.
Artikel Standort, Artikel Standort, Europäische Union.
Wobei Kontinental Europa tut es wahrscheinlich auch noch.
Da ist sowas dann wie Estlands und so dabei.
Wenn wir mal kurz auf die Schnelle gucken. Boah, viel zu teuer.
Okay, Excess Point.
Ich muss mal kurz schauen, weil einen könnte ich noch gebrauchen.
Weil aktuell ist es so, ich habe meine Excess Point so verteilt.
Also keine Ahnung, wir machen mal wieder Massive, Massive Paint Skills.
Das sieht kacke aus. Also hier kann ich mal ahnen.
Boah, Haus.
Massive, Massive Haus, ja.
Pock, Pockhaus.
So, also Keller.
Also hier, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Äh, Erde.
Erde, ist klar.
So, also aktuell habe ich das so.
Sagen wir mal so, Keller.
Wohnort League, ich glaube, aufgrund dieser Zeichnung findet ihr mich garantiert.
So, Keller.
Erdgeschoss, erster Stock.
Also hier, UG heißt, glaube ich, EG.
Und erster Stock.
Und dann ist hier eigentlich Dach, aber da ist nicht viel außer ein paar Kabel.
So, also wie ich das mit dem Excess Point eigentlich vorhatte, ist folgendes.
Image, Post.
Bin ich sicher, ob es das hier ist?
Ja, wie ich es eigentlich vorhatte mit dem Excess Point, habe ich euch ja schon gezeigt, für alle, die nicht dabei waren.
Ich habe mir ja hier so ein Ding an die Decke gemacht, wo ich den Excess Point dran hängen kann.
Ich wollte ihn eigentlich ursprünglich an die Decke hängen, habe ich aber nicht gemacht,
weil die Decke ist mir ein bisschen zu gipsig und zu morsch, ja.
So, so hatte ich es ursprünglich. Da hängt der Excess Point hier kurz unter der Decke.
Kabel habe ich dann auch hinten an die Wand gemacht.
Eigentlich alles gut, so war der Plan.
Das Problem ist jetzt nur, also das war im Wohnzimmer, das war im Wohnzimmer.
Alles 3D gedruckt, das funktioniert tatsächlich ausgesprochen gut, hätte ich selbst nicht gedacht.
Das habe ich übrigens nicht abgeschnitten, das hatte ich noch.
Alles 3D gedruckt, Platte 3D gedruckt, also Mounting Plate 3D gedruckt.
Dann die Schrauben rein geschmolzen mit dem Lötkolben.
Es gibt extra so Inserts, die kann man mit dem Lötkolben mit 3D gedruckt das Material reinschmelzen
und das hält wirklich bombenfest, also so fest, da könntest du dich fast dranhängen,
das ist wirklich sehr, sehr festes Zeug.
2 Schrauben rein gemacht, festgeschraubt und hier noch so Regaldinger ausgedruckt vom 3D Drucker.
So, zumindest wunderbar, funktioniert ohne Probleme.
Einziges Problem ist jetzt nur, worauf ich raus will, also der Excess Point da hing dann ungefähr
von der Seite von vorne betrachtet, von vorne betrachtet ist es irgendwo eher rechts,
also der Excess Point hing dann hier so unter der Decke, das ist der AP
und das hat alles wunderbar funktioniert, das hat alles wunderbar funktioniert,
also das da hier ist ungefähr die Platzierung vom Excess Point, das hat alles wunderbar funktioniert.
Das Einzige ist, lass mal kurz von vorne überlegen, von vorne ist es eher hier so,
ich hab hier unten im Keller so auf der Höhe, hab ich ungefähr, hier steht die, guck mal,
hier im Keller ungefähr steht die Heizung, so, Heizung, ja, die heizt,
wobei die nicht im Keller heizt, die heizt halt.
So, und da hab ich ein ESP8266 dran, an der Wasserzufuhr irgendwo kommt,
dann irgendwo kommt hier so ein Rohr aus der Wand in die Heizung rein, ja.
So, und da ist so eine Valve dran, so ein Ventilding, so.
Und das hab ich automatisiert mit einem ESP32.
Dieser Wasserhahn hier unten für die Wasserzufuhr in die Heizung,
die kann mit einem ESP32 gesteuert werden.
Da drücke ich auf den Knopf, ich mach euch mal einen Screenshot von,
dass ihr seht, wie das dann in meiner Heimautomatisierung aussieht.
Ehrlich gesagt relativ unspektakulär.
Oh, ich mach euch mal kurz einen Screenshot davon, zack.
Also, ich hab hier meine Heimautomatisierung, Knopf, da hier Heizungsdruck,
dann aus, da klick ich drauf, dann fragt er mich nochmal, ob ich einschalten will
und dann wird das Ding hier aufgemacht.
Hier ist ein ESP32 dran, an dem Ding, ja, hier so.
Und dann drücke ich auf Heizung, dann dreht er das auf,
der wasserdruckende Heizung wird nachgefüllt und dann drücke ich drauf,
dann macht er es mir dazu.
So, das ist quasi, und hier in der Mitte sind dann auch die ganzen
tragenden Wände und sowas, ja.
So, und das Problem ist, es funktioniert im gesamten Haus, alles wunderbar.
Ich hab Verbindung, also wenn das hier, wenn es dann hier rausgeht
und das hier ist der, so das hier ist der Garteneingang,
oder das stimmt überhaupt nicht, da vorne betrachtet ist es umgedreht,
dann ist der Garteneingang, egal, also Garteneingang.
Also ich hab bis hier WLAN, überhaupt kein Problem, ja.
Also WLAN hier funktioniert bis zum Garteneingang, ja.
Und hier drüben ist der Gehweg mit den Autos und so, WLAN, kein Problem, alles wunderbar.
Das einzige Dumme ist, das einzige Gerät im ganzen Haus
und auch das, was ich ab und zu mal brauche, ist im Keller.
Das kann ich nicht steuern, weil das ab und zu die Verbindung verliert.
So, das liegt nicht am Access Point, weil wenn ich direkt daneben stehe
mit dem Handy im Keller, dann ist, habe ich 50-60 MBit übertragen,
das ist WLAN technisch gar nicht schlecht, ja.
Vollkommen in Ordnung, aber ich glaube, das liegt dann im ESP32.
Richtiger Firefly-Streamer, ja, tatsächlich, ich hätte es in einem Satz sagen können.
Aber so macht man es, ja, ich bin ja auch lernfähig.
Außerdem muss ich die Leute weiter in der Abo-Falle gefangen halten.
So, und das connectet nicht richtig, deswegen habe ich mir jetzt überlegt,
bisher hatte ich es ja so, bisher, bevor ich auf einen Access Point umgestiegen bin,
hatte ich es ja so, ich hatte im Keller einen Access Point,
ich weile den jetzt mal rein, so einen UniFi Access Point, so.
Ich hatte im Erdgeschoss so einen UniFi Access Point
und ich hatte im ersten Stock so einen UniFi Access Point
und noch einen auf der Seite zur Terrasse hin, so.
Also, so hatte ich das die ganze Zeit, aber die Dinger sind ja weg
und die habe ich jetzt ersetzt durch einen Access Point.
Aber das funktioniert nicht, deswegen dachte ich mir jetzt,
ich kaufe mir noch einen kleinen und stelle einfach hier unten so einen 300,
300 noch was oder so in den Keller.
So, Netzwerkanschluss habe ich, meinen Serverraum,
meinen Serverraum ist sagen wir mal hier, ja,
und das geht dann runter in den Keller und runter ins Erdgeschoss.
Also passt schon, aber das Dumme ist, ich brauche wahrscheinlich noch einen,
dass es wirklich gut funktioniert.
Ansonsten bin ich viel besser als mit den UniFi-Dingern bis jetzt.
Genau, und deswegen wollte ich mal gucken, ob es welche gibt.
Sowas zum Beispiel.
Das ist genau, genau sowas könnte ich gut gebrauchen.
Was ist denn das hier für einer Balance?
New Balance Liverpool, New Balance, das ist eine Schuhmarke,
warum machen die Access Points?
100kW im Serverraum, ne, das braucht gar nicht viel.
Das braucht gar nicht viel.
Das ist ein, oh, ein R650.
Versand aus Großbritannien.
War fünf Tage.
Hier biete ich wahrscheinlich mal mit, denke ich mir.
Kommt noch 70 Euro Versand drauf.
Ach, ich bin nicht billig, der Kram.
Alles klar, bist mit dem Receiver zufrieden?
Du meinst das Ding?
Meinst du das Ding?
Leute, soll ich euch mal das zeigen, was ich gebaut habe
mit meinem Fernsehempfang die letzten zwei Tage?
Dass es endlich gescheit funktioniert.
Ich darf bloß wahrscheinlich keinen Fernsehsender anmachen,
weil dann werde ich instant weggestrikt.
Bevor wir uns dem Monitoring-Thema widmen.
Ja, ich zeige euch das mal kurz.
Das haben letztes Mal ein paar geschrieben.
Man versteht nicht so genau, was ich erzählt habe.
Deswegen zeige ich euch das jetzt einfach mal.
Ich hatte mir auf Anraten des Chats
so ein Ding gekauft.
Und zwar ist das im Prinzip ein Receiver für Fernseh.
Gerade mit einem 8-fach Tuner.
Also du kannst damit beliebig viel aufnehmen und gucken gleichzeitig.
Und dadurch, dass das ein Linux-Receiver ist,
ist das Coole, man kann da noch mehr mitmachen, wenn man will.
Einschränkung bei mir ist,
ich möchte damit nicht Fernseh gucken,
ich möchte von dort streamen.
Also folgendermaßen ist...
Ach so, hier sieht man die Anschlüsse.
Also aktuell habe ich Folgendes angeschlossen.
Netzwerk, eine SSD rein und Input von Vodafone, das war es.
Ja, Fernsehen 2022 hat mich auch schon echt viele Nerven gekostet.
Gerade analoge Fernsehkacke ist wirklich Müll.
So, ich mache mal die VM an.
Und zwar, während die VM startet, erzähle ich noch mal ganz kurz,
ich hatte riesen Probleme mit diesem Teil.
Ich halte die eingebaute Sache, also das eingebaute Interface,
falls man drüber gucken will,
für ein Relikt aus dem letzten Jahrtausend,
das sieht halt so typisch aus, wie man das kennt,
von Fernsehgeräten 1990 bis 2005 oder so.
Ich zeige euch mal ein paar Bilder, ich habe es ja nicht mehr drauf.
Ja, das ist noch eines der neueren.
Also so sieht das dann beispielsweise aus,
von der Bedienung her und so.
Das sieht schon ein bisschen oldschoolig aus.
Bekomme man in Deutschland 2020 denn Full-HD-Fernsehen?
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher.
Ich glaube, die meisten Fernsehsachen werden in Deutschland
entweder mit 720p oder mit 1080i ausgestrahlt.
Die ARD strahlt manchmal aus Gründen,
die sich mir nicht erschließen, 1080i aus.
Warum? Man weiß es nicht.
Ich müsste mal fragen, ob nicht mehr von den Gebühren drin ist.
Ja, das ist auch eine Möglichkeit.
Aber es ist ja nicht für mich.
Hauptsächlich soll ja meine Mutter damit gucken.
Und die guckt gerne Fernsehen.
Die guckt sich auch so komischen Krempel an,
wie Rosamunde Pilcher oder...
Wie heißt der andere Crab?
Inga Lindström.
Das ist so ein Krampf.
Ich kriege da manchmal 5 Minuten mit von.
Das ist ganz, ganz schlimm.
Das ist wirklich...
Nee, Traumschiff guckt sie nicht.
Die mag den Florian Silbereisen.
Ich kenne den Florian Silbereisen.
Florian Silbereisen.
Das ist der, der was mit Helene Fischer hatte.
Mehr weiß ich von Florian Silbereisen nicht.
Ja, nein, das guckt sie sich nicht an,
weil sie den Florian Silbereisen nicht mag.
Monkeys, das ist wirklich schlimm.
Das will man nicht angucken.
Zumindest ist es mir egal.
Ich möchte eine Lösung haben,
die ich möglichst wenig supporten muss
und die einfach funktioniert.
Ich will mich nicht um Fernsehkacke kümmern.
Also, Dinge gekauft.
Und die eingebaute Streaming-Lösung davon
kommt dir vor wie im letzten Jahrtausend.
Und das Kodi-Add-On ist...
Naja, ich will jetzt nicht schlecht reden
für die viele Arbeit,
die da jemand reingesteckt hat.
Aber ich finde, das Kodi-Add-On
ist im Vergleich zu TV-Head-End
ziemlicher Müll.
Das laggt beim Starten.
Das laggt beim Scrollen.
Das züngt sich nur mit 2 Minuten Zeitversatz,
die Timer.
Also, da kommst du wirklich vor wie im letzten Jahrtausend.
Aber die Hardware der Kiste ist gut,
weil die Kiste selbst hat einen 8-fach-Tuner drin,
einen Einschub für eine SSD,
Gigabit-Netzwerk, USB 3.0-Anschlüsse,
Dual-Core, ARM, Linux drauf.
Also, die Kiste, die Hardware ist wirklich nice.
So, und ich wäre nicht ich,
wenn ich das Ding nicht irgendwie dazu
überredet bekommen hätte,
das zu machen, was ich will,
ohne das zu machen,
wie man es sich offiziell so denkt.
Und zwar, ich zeige euch das jetzt mal kurz.
Dazu müssen wir aber erst mal Kodi installieren.
Hat mit dem Thema des heutigen Streams
eigentlich gar nichts zu tun.
Aber nachdem Topix gefragt hat,
zeige ich euch das jetzt mal.
Wir müssen uns Kodi installieren,
dass ich, wobei, geht Kodi installieren
nicht sogar schneller unter Windows
mit den ganzen Plugins?
Egal, wir installieren Kodi mal.
Ich darf halt keine Sender anmachen,
weil ansonsten hatte schon jemals
irgendwas in deinem Stream
mit dem Thema des Streams zu tun.
Ja, wenn ich mich um das Thema des Streams kümmere.
Guck mal, ich meine zum Beispiel der Label-Champ,
da sind wir relativ weit gekommen,
ohne dass ich die fertig gemacht hätte.
Muss ich auch noch fertig machen.
So, Kodi und TV-Header müssen wir installieren.
Das muss man selbst kompilieren.
Monka, warum?
Okay.
So, während er kompiliert,
gucke ich mal in Chat.
Welche Dimension hast du jetzt drauf?
Open, Open TV.
Habe ich drauf, das liegt daran,
weil das Linux-technisch einfach um Jahre
vor dem ist, was VTI hat.
Linux-technisch ist VTI
irgendwas aus dem letzten Millennium gefühlt
und Open TV halbwegs aktuell.
Was mir jetzt auch zugute gekommen ist,
weil damit kann ich machen, was ich machen will.
Iget, wer guckt denn,
wer guckt denn Germany's Next Top Model?
Okay, genug, sonst gibt es den Laden nicht mehr.
Native 4K ist nicht möglich.
Das ist schon möglich,
aber da haben die öffentlich-rechtlichen Sender
bei uns in Deutschland keinen Bock drauf.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ZDF schon mal 4K übertragen hat.
Machen könnten die das wahrscheinlich.
Ja, all die uns pleiten, keine Unheil...
Ja, komm, ich meine, wo kämen wir denn dahin?
Wo kämen wir denn dahin,
wenn wir irgendwie halbwegs mit der Zeit gehen würden bei
Milliarden Gebühren, die man bekommt
und zum größten Teil nicht für Content ausgibt,
sondern um die Rente zu bezahlen von irgendwelchen
ehemaligen öffentlich-rechtlichen Mitarbeitern
und den Super-High-IQ-Ganzel.
Wie heißen die Chefs von denen?
Die heißen dann die Chefs,
wie heißt das bei öffentlich-rechtlichen Mitarbeitern?
Das sind nicht die Chefs,
das sind nicht die Programmanager,
das sind die, so der Chef von ARD,
das Intendanten genau,
die brauchen natürlich auch Massive-Kohle,
was weiß ich, irgendwie 350.000 Euro,
nee, oder mehr, fragt mir nicht.
Keine Ahnung, kann man nicht erwarten,
dass man da irgendwelche zeitgemäße Technik
oder so an Start bringt,
da müssen 720p ausreichen.
Nein, die streben nicht in 4K.
So.
Okay, Cody ist eigentlich...
Also, normalerweise ist es folgenderweise gedacht,
man verwendet diese Box,
also, ich hab ja ein Shield-TV im Wohnzimmer,
was halt von der Bedienung,
das ist ein ganz normales Android-TV,
zeig euch mal, das Interface von meinem
ist jetzt nicht wirklich repräsentativ,
weil das Einzige, was ich im Video gezeigt habe,
ist halt im Endeffekt mein Cony-Oberfläche.
Ja, das Ding sieht halt so aus,
wie man sich ein Android-TV vorstellt im Endeffekt.
Du hast die ganzen offiziellen Apps,
du kannst die ganzen App-Apps
und offiziellen Apps, du kannst YouTube gucken,
Native, du kannst Native Prime Video gucken,
Netflix gucken und die allermeisten Apps,
die es halt so gibt, Android-Apps,
kannst du direkt über den Store installieren,
wenn es keine Android-TV-Version gibt,
kannst du dir das sideloaden als APK und gut ist.
Das Shield-TV ist nicht das Einzige.
Ähm, da sag ich gleich was zu.
Das Shield-TV ist nicht das Einzige,
es gibt jede Menge Android-TV-Dinger,
es gibt Low-Low-Low-End,
beispielsweise den Fire-TV-Stick.
Der Fire-TV-Stick ist halt standardmäßig
ziemlich Amazon-verseucht
und ist von der Hardware auch
mehr schlecht als recht, aber es ist ein Android-TV.
Und es gibt dann auch diese Roku-Kisten
und alles Mögliche.
Ich habe ein Shield-TV seit 2017,
ich bin zufrieden damit,
dass es bis heute noch keinen Grund hat.
Also das habe ich als Fernseher dran,
als einziges Gerät,
wobei stimmt nicht,
meine Switch ist drüben noch dran im Wohnzimmer.
Ansonsten ist nur das Shield-TV dran.
So, und gedacht ist es eigentlich,
dass man, also die offizielle Streaming-Lösung
von dieser Kiste, also es gibt zwei Sachen.
Wenn man mit dieser Kiste Fernseher gucken will,
entweder den Fernseher HDMI dran stöpseln,
will ich aber nicht, weil ich möchte
auf Android-TV-Fernsehe gucken.
So, also, die offizielle Streaming-Lösung
sieht folgendermaßen aus, oder offiziell?
Ja, das Offiziellste, was es gibt.
Es gibt einen Kodi-Addon für dieses Ding,
das nennt sich so.
Und das wird auch noch aktiv maintained
und so ist es gar nicht.
Das funktioniert okay.
Ja, okay, da hast du recht, Erik.
Am allerschlimmsten ist Android-TV
auf den Sony-Fernseher.
Ich habe einen Sony-Fernseher mit Android-TV drauf.
Das ist ruckelig und kannst du nicht vergessen.
Habe ich aber auch nie geupdatet,
habe ich aber auch nie ins Internet angeschlossen,
dürften sie gar nicht.
Mehr Forks als Sterne.
Tatsächlich.
So, damit streamt man normalerweise.
Und das hatte ich auch so eingerichtet,
aber das hat unglaublich Probleme gemacht.
Ich habe mein Kodi gestartet
mit diesem Plugin.
Es hat eine Minute EPG gesynkt.
Ich habe Aufnahmen gelöscht.
Es hat 30 Sekunden rumgeleckt.
Das war nicht benutzbar.
So, und was ich jetzt gemacht habe ist,
ich dachte mir, wenn ich doch schon
ein modernes Linux habe auf meinem Receiver,
wir loggen uns jetzt mal kurz
auf die Setup-Box vom Fernseher ein.
Wir loggen uns jetzt per SSH
auf meinen Fernsehtuner quasi ein.
Wenn ich doch schon ein Linux drauf habe,
dann kann ich da drauf doch vielleicht auch
einen ordentlichen Streaming-Server installieren.
Oder habe ich als erstes mal geguckt,
wie sieht es denn aus?
Gibt es Docker?
Habe ich festgestellt.
Okay, wer hätte das gedacht?
Auf einem Linux-TV-Receiver
gibt es kein Docker.
Schau mal doof.
Habe ich weiter geguckt.
LXC gibt es auch nicht.
LXD gibt es auch nicht.
Snap gibt es auch nicht.
Nichts.
Keine Containerisierungs-Sachen möglich.
Okay, das ist doof.
Wie kriege ich da jetzt einen ordentlichen
Streaming-Server drauf?
Und dann habe ich mal
die blöde Idee gehabt,
guckst du einfach mal,
ob es TV-Headern drauf gibt.
Und siehe da,
es gibt TV-Headern drauf.
Die CPU ist nicht so alt für Docker.
Nein.
Ich habe mir die Docker-Binary drauf kopiert
und es funktioniert prinzipiell,
aber es scheitert daran, dass der Colonel
keinen C-Group-Support hat.
Es gibt TV-Headern drauf.
Für das das TV-Headern nicht entwickelt wird,
gibt es ganz schön viele Comets.
Aber es funktioniert.
Aber es ist in Ordnung.
TV-Headern ist das,
was ich auch benutzt habe,
um meinen Kodi
auf dem Shield-TV zu streamen.
So.
Und dann habe ich TV-Headern installiert.
Oh.
Was jetzt?
Leute, hat es geleckt?
Hat der Stream geleckt?
Es gibt keinen Release.
Ja, das ist nicht schlimm.
Es ist nicht geleckt. Master installieren.
Zumindest jetzt habe ich TV-Headern installiert
und ich habe das
Native-Interface
von diesem...
Also so sieht das Interface
normalerweise aus.
Das Native-Interface...
Also das sieht wirklich aus wie
aus dem letzten Jahr 1000 Leute. Glaubst du mir?
Das wollt ihr eigentlich nicht haben.
Das Interface habe ich einfach deaktiviert.
In it... In it 4
gemacht. In it 4 schaltet
alles, was es dort
mitgeliefert wird, erstmal aus.
Dann habe ich TV-Headern installiert
und ich mache euch jetzt mal TV-Headern auf
auf meinem Linux-Receiver.
Also nur, dass wir es richtig verstehen.
Mein Linux-TV-Receiver hat einen SSH-Zugang
und ein Web-Interface.
Danach machen wir auch Zubix.
So. Und da sieht man
guckt mal da.
EPG ist schon mal da.
Und er erkennt
8 Tuner.
Das Problem
ist nur, der hat die Tuner
standardmäßig gar nicht erkannt.
Weil wenn ich jetzt hier mal auf DVB-Inputs
gehe, sieht man
das sind keine regulären Tuner.
Das sind SAT-IP-Tuner.
Obwohl dieses Ding,
diese Box hier, ein 8-fach
Tuner eingebaut hat. Das Problem
ist, dass der Treiber so
beschissen ist.
Das TV-Headend mit dem Treiber
hier, kann ich euch
zeigen.
DVB, Adapter 0
hier, das sind
Frontend 1 bis 7.
Das sind die Tuner,
die da drin stecken.
PCI-Express-Tuner.
Was ist Zubix?
Das ist eine Monitoring-Lösung.
So. Und
TV-Headend hat Probleme
mit den Tunern. Deswegen
Massive-Fivehead
habe ich ein Projekt auf GitHub gefunden.
Mini-SAT-IP.
Und Mini-SAT-IP
ist ein
Tuner
zu
Web...
Nein, Schwachsinn. Ein Tuner zu
Socket-Bridge
quasi. Also du kannst quasi
per IP mit dem Tuner reden.
Und die Übersetzung zu dem
Treibergeschiss macht dann Mini-SAT-IP.
Es ist da noch eine
andere Lösung darauf vorinstalliert,
die hat bei mir aber nicht funktioniert.
Also habe ich Mini-SAT-IP
drauf gemacht. Wir sind übrigens per SSH
auf meinem Receiver für den Fernsehgrad.
Für alle, die neu dazu kommen.
Deswegen habe ich Mini-SAT-IP gestartet.
Mini-SAT-IP hier gestartet.
Mini-SAT-IP binden
nur auf Localhost.
Threading ausschalten, weil es rumbarkt.
TCP-Mode aktivieren.
Caching-Verzeichnis eingeben.
DVBC verwenden.
Und das Web-Interface
bereitstellen.
So. Und nachdem ich das gemacht habe,
sehe ich in TV-Headend
meine 8 Tuner.
Und die funktionieren auch.
Das kann ich euch beweisen, dass die
funktionieren, wenn ich jetzt nämlich mal
Kodi starte.
Ja, wir aktivieren das Addon.
Dann tragen wir jetzt hier einfach mal ein.
Warum hast du SAT-IP nicht direkt im Kodi?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Das liegt daran,
dass du SAT-IP
im Kodi nur mit dem IP-TV
Addon machen kannst. Und das IP-TV
Addon, es sei denn du kennst was anderes,
das IP-TV Addon
hat Probleme, erstens
mit dem EPG und zweitens kann es
nicht aufnehmen.
Und hier ist ja eine
Festplatte drinne. Hier ist eine SSD
drin mit 2TB,
wo man Fernsehaufnahmen drauf speichern kann.
Übrigens, das wird
mit dem Zappix später auch noch eine Herausforderung,
dieses Ding hier zu monitoren.
Ich hab schon mal
Zappix-Agent drauf kopiert.
Weiße Voraussicht.
Ich beweise euch,
dass das funktioniert. Und zwar
wir tragen jetzt hier mal den Streaming-Server ein.
Username
Massive Password
Ok,
das sollte eigentlich schon funktionieren. Und jetzt
muss ich glaube ich nochmal neu starten.
By the way,
ich benutze das nicht.
Also wer sich jetzt hier wundert, warum so komische
Dinge geguckt werden, ich guck das nicht. Das ist nicht für mich.
So, und schon
hat man Verbindung zum
Streaming-Server für Fernseh, zu den 8 Tunern.
Kann jetzt den EPG reingucken.
Und Rosamunde Pilcher
können wir uns jetzt angucken.
Jetzt guckt euch mal an, wie schnell das funktioniert.
Zack, an ist. So und ich mach gleich wieder
aus, weil ihr wisst
Toss und
sowas.
Also sprich, ich kann hier
einfach Fernsehtunen und es läuft.
Easy.
Ich weiß ja nicht, ob ich was anmachen darf, weil
ansonsten ist direkt Toss angesagt.
Bibel-TV, das habe ich glaube ich
gar nicht drinne. Haben wir Bibel-TV?
Ne, keine Ahnung.
So, und irgendjemand
hat gefragt, wie sieht das
mit dem schnell umschalten aus? Da sag ich jetzt gleich
was dazu.
Das ist richtig, To Do App,
das war doch nur was zum testen.
Ähm...
Wo ist denn der? Wo war denn hier die Frage
mit dem... Ach, hier oben drüber.
Kann OpenART-TV
die vollständige Antwort des 8-Faktors inklusive
Fast-Tapping, war das nicht... Also,
theoretisch ist das sowas,
was du sagst. Die
3-mal Implementierung unter OpenART-TV
hat manche
Vorzüge nicht,
die
das unter dem VTI-Image
hat, aber
ich zeig dir mal, wie schnell das... Ich weiß gar nicht,
wie man mit Kodi umschaltet. Aber
du siehst, wie schnell das mit dem Tunen geht. Keine Ahnung, wir
schalten jetzt mal um. Guck mal, wir schalten
jetzt mal um von dem in
dem anderen Sender. Oh, Alter!
Dieses Drecksprogramm, man!
Kann man das Kodi irgendwie klein machen,
dass ich...
Ich möchte Kodi irgendwie
verkleinern, dass ich nicht...
Ich möchte nicht den ganzen Bildschirm ausfüllen, weil ansonsten
gibt's irgendwelche Strikes oder so im Zweifelsfall
noch. Äh, wie schaltet man den Kodi
um? Kodi, Switch, Channel,
Shortcut. Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich guck kein Fernseher.
Äh,
Channel.
Zero.
Go between last two live channels.
Zero, okay.
Wir schalten mal um. Also, pass
mal auf, wie schnell das ist.
Also, wir gucken
jetzt... Wir gucken
gar nichts. Falls einer zuguckt, Leute, wir gucken keinen...
Ich mach's nur zum Demonstrieren.
So, Switch.
Dahin. Ausschalten.
Switch, Rosamunde,
Pilcher. So, und ich zeig dir jetzt mal, wie schnell...
Ich zeig dir jetzt mal, wie schnell man umschalten kann.
So, hier läuft jetzt Rosamunde, Pilcher.
Umschalten aufs erste.
Also, ganz ehrlich,
das reicht doch an
Umschaltzeiten, oder?
Weil, viel schneller muss das nicht sein.
Ich mein, gut, wenn man den ganzen Tag
bei 350
pro Gramm immer von 0 auf 350
zappt, ist das vielleicht
zu langsam, aber
insgesamt ist das, glaube ich, okay.
Ja. Also, ja, du wirst
theoretisch unter VTI, gerade wenn du es direkt
angeschlossen hast, wahrscheinlich sogar noch
minimal schneller, aber so ist es
vollkommen in Ordnung.
So. Und
deswegen ist jetzt der große Vorteil.
Ich hab
mein Kodi auf dem Shield TV,
also, im Prinzip sieht's bei mir
auf dem Fernseh exakt so aus wie hier,
Kodi auf dem Shield TV
mit TV Headend Plugin,
TV Headend auf dem Lennox
Receiver drauf,
Mini Satt IP zum Anstreuen der
Tuner. Ich hab Updates
deaktiviert, sowohl Kodi auf dem
Shield TV, ich hab Shield TV Updates deaktiviert,
ich hab Updates auf dem Receiver.
Das heißt, wenn der Scheiß jetzt funktioniert
in dieser Konstellation, dann wird's
auch einfach weiter funktionieren.
So sieht's aus.
Ja.
Und, ähm,
das geht nur,
sollte man an der Stelle vielleicht auch nochmal hervorheben,
das geht nur dank ordentlichem
Lennox Support auf
dieser Kiste.
Ja, wird es, wird es, guck.
Wird es. Es ist zwar keine
sonderlich aktuelle Version.
Das hier ist die Commit ID,
aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob's die Commit ID ist von dem,
den sie genommen haben.
Hat das so was wie Info
oder so?
What the fuck, Alter.
TV Headends.
Was haben wir denn hier zu bieten,
die, die Version?
Ich kann dir sagen, von wann das TV Headend ist.
Vielleicht steht da irgendwas.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Was? Wir können doch im Web Interface gucken,
dann sieht man das doch.
Ähm, ich will nicht wissen, wann das installiert wurde.
Ich will wissen, wann, äh, was das für eine Version ist.
About.
About. Hier.
Da.
Vom 14.3.
Das ist doch eine Version.
Das ist doch eigentlich ganz okay.
Build. Toggle Detail.
Ja, alles klar.
Ähm, okay, bis 2000, bis 2020.
Das ist doch eine etwas älteren Version, wie's aussieht.
Gucken wir mal, von wann das Commit ist.
Geht's ab.
TV Headends.
Schauen wir mal, von wann das Commit ist.
2020 kann durchaus sein.
Dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Aber nachdem es nur Copyright bis 2020 drauf steht.
Kein Schimmer.
Es ist wohl eine etwas ältere Version von TV Headends.
Aber ganz ehrlich, juckt mich nicht, es funktioniert.
Ah, hier, Commits.
Also das Commit ist von 16.12.2020.
Wobei ich halt echt keine Ahnung hab, ob es auch wirklich das letzte ist.
Keine Ahnung. Ist auch wurscht.
Zumindest kann man da drüber Fernsehen gucken.
Streamen an beliebig viele Kisten.
Und man muss sich nicht mit dem Crap-Streaming auseinandersetzen.
Was die Box standardmäßig hergibt.
Ich kann jetzt schön auf meinem Shield-TV gucken und alles ist gut.
So, jetzt hätten wir das auch abgehakt.
Aber offiziell geht da nichts.
Doch, also, ich hab mehrere Sachen ausprobiert.
Ich muss gleich nochmal den Chat lesen.
Doch, doch, ich hab mehrere Sachen ausprobiert.
Du kannst in TV Head Anti-Tuner direkt verwenden.
Das geht.
Ich hab's bloß bisher nicht geschafft, dass der nicht so viel buffert.
Also es funktioniert, es funktioniert auch ruckelfrei.
Aber wenn du eine Aufnahme startest, dann braucht er irgendwie 30 Sekunden,
bis er anfängt auf die Festplatte zu schreiben.
Weil er wahrscheinlich erst vom Tuner genug Daten braucht oder sonst was.
Ich glaube die Treiber sind da ein bisschen verbackt.
Aber du kannst auch die Treiber, also du kannst die Tuner direkt im TV Head Anti verwenden.
Die sieht er auch.
Und das geht prinzipiell.
Dann kannst du SAT-IP verwenden oder SAT-PI oder SAT-PI oder so.
Das wird mitgeliefert bei OpenARTV.
Als Plugin sogar.
Das ist im Prinzip das gleiche wie Mini-SAT-IP.
Hat bloß ein paar andere Probleme.
Mini-SAT-IP ist auch in den Repos drinne.
Du kannst, du kannst hier drinnen direkt.
Das ist wirklich vom Setup her total simpel.
Du installierst einfach Mini-SAT.
Mini-SAT-IP.
Startest das mit dem Befehl, den ich vorhin hier PS.
Du startest das da drauf.
So.
Und dann installierst du TV Head und startest TV Head und er sieht alle Tuner.
Du musst nichts sonst mehr konfigurieren.
Ich würde mich einfach freuen, dass das funktioniert.
So, jetzt gehen wir mal ganz schnell auch mal den Chat durch.
Doch.
Das ist OpenWRT.
Das ist das OpenWRT-Package-Format.
Die nächste Stufe wäre ein Mini-PC mit Kodi.
Das ist nicht die nächste Stufe.
Das ist kompletter Rückschritt.
Mini-PC mit Kodi und TV-O-Kade.
Ich hatte schon mehrere Anläufe in dieser Richtung.
Aber finde einen 8-fach-Tuner.
Und finde alles, das so schön in einer Box ist, wie das.
Das ist tatsächlich die beste Lösung, die mir so einfällt aktuell.
Ich hatte zwischenzeitlich auch mal einen Raspberry Pi.
Mit einem USB-Tuner hatte ich auch.
Hatte einen USB-Tuner.
Hatte ich auch.
Hatte Probleme mit der SSD gehabt.
Und an der Box ist halt schön, dass alles in einem ist.
Du hast bei dieser Box alles drinne inklusive Tuner.
Du stöpselst es per Netzwerk an.
Du lest über USB das Image.
Hier machst du die Festplatte rein.
Und du hast alles in einer Box.
Rüber ins Wohnzimmer gestellt und Ruhe ist.
Und ich hoffe, ich muss mich nie wieder die nächsten 50 Jahre damit beschäftigen.
Aber es funktioniert einfach.
By the way, und wer mir nicht glaubt, dass ich versucht habe, darauf Docker zum Laufen zu lassen.
Oh, ich hab's gelöscht, Leute, vergesst.
Ich kann's euch nicht zeigen.
Wie geht's?
Aber ich hab's noch in der History.
Ich hab versucht, Docker drauf laufen zu lassen.
Und er kackt ab, weil C-Groups nicht richtig gemountet sind.
Hat nicht funktioniert.
Aber okay, von einem...
Von einem...
Von einem etwas älteren ARMv7 Dual Core
kann man da wahrscheinlich jetzt auch kernel-technisch nicht so viel erwarten.
Aber es liegt nicht an der CPU.
Die ist neu genug.
Das ist eher der Kernelsache, dass sie den wohl nicht mit dem richtigen Support für Container kompiliert haben.
Zumal es auch nur ein 32-Bit-System ist.
Ja, aber ganz ehrlich, ich komm auch ohne Linux-Container auf meinem TV-Receiver klar.
Welche kernel-Version?
Relativ akt... also nicht wirklich top-aktuell, aber relativ aktuell.
Hier.
Hier eins.
Was ist denn das?
Was ist denn das? Kernel.
Was war das? 4.1?
Ist von irgendein Kernel in ursprüngliches Release mal 2015.
Und jetzt müsste man halt gucken, wovon 4.1.20 ist.
Hey, das ist halbwegs aktuell.
Ohne Scheiß.
OpenVTI hat einen Kernel von... keine Ahnung.
2012 oder so.
Keine Ahnung wann das released wurde.
Also gebaut wurde der Kernel hier Februar 2022.
Linux-Kernel released. Also hier, guck mal.
Der Kernel ist von März 2016.
Also, das ist... auch wenn sich das erstmal nicht so anhört.
Also ein 6-Jahre... das ist ziemlich genau 6 Jahre alt, der Kernel.
Das ist für solche Receiver-Boxen gar nicht mal so alt.
Um Längen besser als VTI, was da an Libraries und so dabei ist.
So, jetzt haben wir uns mal den Linux-Receiver angeguckt.
Mal kurz Chat durchgehen.
Ja, verstehe ich.
Das ist das Gute an dem, die haben sogar Hardware-Transcoder drauf.
Wie viele Stunden ich dafür gebraucht hab?
Ja, zwei Tage hab ich rumgebastelt, immer mal wieder.
Ich hab da bestimmt 13, 14 Stunden dran gesessen, bis das alles funktioniert hat.
Man muss ja viel rumprobieren, obwohl jetzt ist es easy.
Also jetzt, was ich euch erzählt hab, ihr würdet das in einer halben bis Stunde einrichten.
Ach, eine Sache hab ich vergessen.
Falls es wirklich jemand bauen will bei sich daheim, sowas in der Richtung.
Eine Sache hab ich vergessen, das muss ich euch noch zeigen.
Das müsst ihr einstellen.
Und zwar, wenn ihr beim Setup von euren Tuner-Inputs seid.
Ihr müsst hier draufgehen auf den Ordner.
Alter, wie lange ich gesucht hab, bis ich dieses Settings-Menü gefunden hab.
Ihr müsst auf den Ordner gehen von euren Tunern.
Und dann müsst ihr hier reingehen und einstellen Maximum Pits 20.
Das ist soweit ich verstanden hab, wie viele Sender er gleichzeitig auf einem Tuner empfängt.
Weil potentiell kannst du ja quasi alle Sender, die auf einer Frequenz liegen, gleichzeitig empfangen, wenn du den Tuner auf diese Frequenz tunest.
Also wenn du quasi hier auf die Frequenz gehst von, keine Ahnung, sagen wir mal, das hier wäre die Frequenz von ARD.
Dann kannst du quasi auf dieser Frequenz alle 60 Channels auf einmal empfangen, wenn du auf diese Frequenz tunst.
Und das ist ein bisschen viel.
Und man musste den limitieren auf 20 Sender pro Frequenz.
Was reicht, weil in der Regel wollt ihr nicht mehr als ein Sender gleichzeitig gucken.
Ansonsten habt ihr acht Tuner, es ist nicht so, als geht es einem irgendwie aus.
So, und ganz wichtig, was ihr auch noch machen müsstet, ist das hier.
Also ihr müsst hier 20 eintragen und hier oben sagen, dass er TCP-Mode verwenden soll.
Wenn ihr nämlich nicht TCP-Mode verwendet für die SAT-IP-Tuner, dann Pixels und er hat Pegglecloth as fuck.
Also TCP-Mode aktivieren.
TCP-Mode aktivieren bei Mini SAT-IP minus O machen.
Patrick, ich könnte mehr damit empfangen.
Ich könnte damit quasi, ich habe acht Tuner und kann auf acht Frequenzen tunen.
Das bedeutet, theoretisch, ach so, wenn ich auf 20 stelle.
Ja, im Prinzip, im Prinzip kann ich 120 Sender gleichzeitig empfangen.
Und aufnehmen im Prinzip so viel ich will, wenn die halt auch auf diesem, also aufnehmen und schauen ist das Gleiche.
Also wenn ich mit einem Tuner einen Sender gucke, dann kann ich den aufnehmen und das braucht nur einen Stream.
Oder umgedreht, wenn ich was aufnehme und Tune dann da drauf, dann ist es der gleiche Stream im Endeffekt.
Also ja, ich könnte im Prinzip 160 Sender gleichzeitig empfangen.
Was halt kein Mensch brauche.
Ahzi, danke für den Snap. Kannst du die Hardware nochmal zeigen? Hier das Ding.
Das ganze gibt es auch noch als Duo. Der Duo hat eine Quad-Core-CPU. Der hier hat bloß eine Dual-Core-CPU.
Aber ganz ehrlich, für meinen Linux-Receiver reicht das.
Ja, Nodex Porter auch schon am Start für unsere Zappix-Versuche später.
Du kannst das gesamte TV-Programm archivieren, wenn du drei Stück davon hast.
Theoretisch schon, ja. Oder was ich machen würde ist, ich würde das Ding mal austesten, ob es auch mit mehr als 20 Pits geht.
Weil theoretisch kannst du mit einer Box alle Sender empfangen, die Vodafone ausliefert.
Ich weiß halt nicht, ob das mit TV-Headern verkraftet.
Kann das Ding Pay-TV? Ja, kann es. Und das kann Pay-TV und, das muss man jetzt leise sagen, weil das macht natürlich keiner von uns.
Das Ding kann auch, das Ding hat auch zwei Smartcard-Reader.
Und ich habe gelesen, ich habe es nicht ausprobiert, weil ich habe keine Smartcard in der Richtung.
Ich habe mir mal überlegt vor ein paar Wochen, ob ich mir sowas für mein Sony-Fernseh holen soll und habe es aber nicht gemacht.
Der frisst die Standard Vodafone Smartcard, habe ich gelesen, keine Ahnung, müsst ihr dann ausprobieren, wenn ihr das ausprobieren wollt.
Der frisst angeblich die Standard Vodafone Smartcard ohne Probleme, obwohl das eigentlich nicht passieren sollte bei unzertifizierten Geräten.
Also theoretisch kann man einfach die Standard Vodafone Smartcard reinmachen und damit dann die privaten Sender in HD gucken, wenn man das will.
Ja, das habe ich gelesen, Paints Jam.
Überlebt TV-Headern Mini Satabee Neustart der Box oder muss man basteln?
Ähm, ja und nein, also die Settings bleiben vorhanden. Was du machen musst ist, wenn die Box neu gestartet wird.
Ich wollte nämlich nicht an den Boot-Settings rumspielen. Was du machen musst, wenn du die Box rebootest, du baust dir einen Skript,
innert 4 und dann startest du über das Skript Mini Satabee. Du machst dir quasi Mini Startskript, was du ausführen musst nach dem Reboot.
Oder alternativ, du trägst dein Startskript in die RC Local ein und wird beim Reboot gestartet.
Das kannst du machen. Aber die Settings und die anderen Sachen überlebt das natürlich.
Aber ich habe mir noch keine Gedanken darüber gemacht, wie ich das ordnungsgemäß rebooten lasse.
Ich mache mir ein Startskript, was die 3 Befehle ausführt, die man ausführen muss.
Im Endeffekt musst du einfach nur 3 Sachen ausführen. Du führst innert 4 aus.
Das schaltet dieses ganze Enigma Zeug und eingebaute Zeug ab auf dem Tuner.
Dann startest du mit diesen Parametern Mini Sat IP und dann startest du TV Header. Fertig.
System D?
Meinst du das hat System D das Ding? Das Ding ist oldschool. Das System hat innert V. Dingsbums hier.
Da hat doch kein System D. So modern sind die nur auch wieder nicht, als hätten die System D.
Die haben ganz klassisches Innit. Wie hießen das Ding? System V Innit?
Keine Ahnung, wir können mal gucken, was für ein Innit-System die haben.
Was passiert denn eigentlich, wenn ich hier nach Innit suche?
Hier. System V Innit hat das Ding am Start.
Ja, und die Shell... Oh, das ist tatsächlich eine Bash. Keine Busybox Shell.
Okay, immerhin. Warum kein Arch drauf? Weil die Firmen werden nicht auf Arch basiert.
Sondern auf irgendeinem... auf irgendeinem Open-WRT-Geschütz oder so. Keine Ahnung.
Aber wisst ihr, was dann auch krass ist? Du kannst, wenn man sich das mal so überlegt,
du kannst auf deine Linux-Box, also du kannst auf einem Linux-TV-Receiver bis zu
6.850 verschiedene Packages installieren.
Es ist schon geil, oder, dass wir sowas wie Linux haben. Muss man wirklich mal sagen.
Dadurch ist vieles einfacher geworden. Vielleicht nicht unbedingt Linux auf dem Desktop, aber...
Okay. Welche TV hat einen... oder besser gesagt, im Wohnzimmer gibt es einen...
Hab ich doch hier im Video gezeigt. Hab ich doch hier im...
Wohnzimmer. Da. Das ist ein Sony KD55XE9005.
Beste Produktnamen überhaupt. 55XE9005. Obvious. Obvious.
Aber der ist schon ein paar Jahre... Wie gesagt, der ist 5 Jahre alt. Mittlerweile
gibt es da sicherlich schon bessere.
Nee, vergiss es. Das mach ich nicht. Das Ding läuft jetzt und das Ding bleibt so.
Und ich mach da keinen Handschlag mehr dran. So Leute, kommen wir mal zum eigentlichen
Thema des heutigen Streams. Zabbix. Oder wie die coolen Leute sagen, Zabbix.
Leute, Zabbix oder Zabbix? Wie sagt ihr das, falls ihr das sagt?
Aussprache.
Zabux. Moment. Zabux.
Zabbix. Zabbix. Okay. Zabbix.
Zabbix. Zabbix.
Zabbix. Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid. Zabbix.
Wenn überhaupt. Mir ist schon der Hals übelst trocken. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich so lange
schriebe. So, also Zabbix. Und zwar aktuell ist mein Monitoring daheim
recht rudimentär. Mein Monitoring daheim sieht aktuell so aus.
Das ist alles. Ich checke, ob meine Kameras erreichbar sind.
Ich checke, ob der DNS Server erreichbar ist, der MQTT Server.
Ich checke, ob der Ayaya Server erreichbar ist. Was das ist, könnt ihr euch denken?
Nee, das müsst ihr euch nicht denken. Ich kann es euch sagen.
Das ist meine Kiste, die hinten im rechten, in meinem Serverraum steht.
Also quasi die einzige größere Serverkiste, die ich habe.
Das ist der Ayaya Server. Nein, das hat nichts mit Handtiles oder sonst was zu tun.
Chat, Alter. Nein, das ist die ganz normale Serverkiste. Kameras, Raspberry Pi,
Shield TV. Zeug. Das ist mir ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen wenig.
Weil ich zum Beispiel, wo wir hier gerade dabei sind, zum Beispiel, was ich auch
überwachen will, ist, ob die Festplatte hier voll läuft.
Das lässt sich mit ein bisschen Tricks in Uptime Cuma machen.
Weil in Uptime Cuma kannst du zum Beispiel HTTP-Checks machen und dann
auswerten die Response. Also ich könnte die Response vielleicht irgendwie
auswerten mit einem lokalen Script, was da läuft, auf Port 80 lauscht
und dann den Festplattenbelegung zurückgibt. Also vielleicht.
Aber wo spätestens das mit so einer einfachen Lösung wie Uptime Cuma
ans Limit gerät, ist, wenn du dann auch sagst, okay, ich hätte ganz gerne mal
einen Graf. So, dann kannst du natürlich sagen, okay, dann exportiere ich das
Ganze als Prometheus-Metriken, installiere ich noch einen Prometheus oder
Prometheus, wie die coolen Leute sagen. Installiere ich noch einen Prometheus,
mache noch einen Grafana dabei und haste nicht gesehen. Man kann total ausflippen.
Oder aber man probiert es mit einer All-in-one-Lösung wie Zabbix oder Nagios
zum Beispiel. Es gibt sich Lösungen. Also, was ich schon mal verwendet habe
alles. Also, ich habe bei mir daheim eine ganze Zeit lang Prometheus-Grafana
verwendet. Habe ich immer noch ein paar Dashboards, aber gucke ich eigentlich so gut
wie als ich habe für meine Zertifikate aktuell ein Dashboard. Aber ich bin da
ein bisschen von weggekommen, weil ich festgestellt habe, dass für meine
Anwendungszwecke daheim Prometheus-Grafana, also Grafana für die eigentliche
Visualisierung richtig geil ist. Aber Prometheus für meinen Geschmack daheim
nicht das Beste ist, weil, zumindest für meinen Anwendungszweck, jeder hat da
andere Dinge. Und zwar, weil ich hauptsächlich Blackbox-Monitoring mache.
Also, ich will keine Anwendungsmetriken überwachen. Mir ist klar, dass man das
mit Prometheus und Grafana ohne Probleme machen kann. Also, du hast ja so Sachen
wie den Blackbox-Exporter und du kannst im Zweifelsfall da auch anderweitig
Dinge reinpumpen. Aber es ist nicht so schön. Also, man merkt Grafana und vor
allem Prometheus an, dass die Tools nicht für klassisches Monitoring gemacht
wurden. Ist der Host ab oder ist der Host down oder ist das Service ab oder ist
der Service down. Man merkt Prometheus ganz klar an, dass es dafür gemacht ist,
dass Anwendungen Metriken exportieren. Also, dass man zum Beispiel eine Java-Anwendung
hat oder eine.NET-Anwendung, die dann per Prometheus oder zum Beispiel meine
Heizungssteuerung unten, der habe ich ja auch mal einen Prometheus-Exporter
verpasst, falls sich da noch einer dran erinnert. Und, dass die Anwendungen selbst
exportieren. Zum Beispiel, wie viele Garbage-Collector-Runs haben sie oder
wie viel RAM-Verbrauch und wie viele Threads laufen aktuell. Wie viele User
sind gerade eingeloggt. Das ist zum Beispiel auch so was. Versucht mal in
eurem Monitoring-System ordentlich reinzubekommen. Wird das gar nicht so
einfach. Versucht mal ordentlich reinzubekommen, wie viele User gerade im
System sind. Was relativ einfach ist, ist offene TCP-Sessions. Das ist relativ
einfach. Aber wie viele User sind eingeloggt und haben gerade aktive
Sessions, das ist gar nicht so einfach. Gibt es Möglichkeiten schon lange, ja
gerade wenn du Loadbalancer davor hast und sowas. Aber so wirklich easy ist das
nicht. Und da ist halt das, wo Prometheus und Grafana wirklich glänzen.
Nein, ich meine nicht diesen komischen Alien-Film. Da ist das, wo Prometheus
und Grafana halt richtig glänzen. Du baust nämlich in deine Anwendung ein
Prometheus-Exporter, der unter anderem sowas exportiert wie logged-in-users.
Und dann kannst du das natürlich super visualisieren. Die Sache ist plus die,
bei mir daheim möchte ich weniger Anwendungsmetriken monitoren, als eher
ist der Raspberry Pi im Keller ab und down, läuft der Speicher darauf voll,
läuft mein Zertifikat ab für meinen MQTT-Server bei Hetzner. Solche
Geschichten. Also ich möchte mehr oder weniger eigentlich fast nur
Blackbox-Monitoring machen. Das geht mit Prometheus auch, aber merkt, dass es
nicht dafür entwickelt wurde. Und spätestens bei so Sachen wie Netzwerkgeräte
über SNMP-Monitoren, da hat Prometheus nicht so wirklich die Stärken. Du kannst
zwar auch einen SNMP-Exporter starten und dann ist die Auswertung im Grafana
natürlich wieder richtig geil, weil rein Visualisierung macht Grafana
eigentlich, gibt es eigentlich nichts besseres im Endeffekt. Aber da wird es
dann schon eklig. Du brauchst dann für jeden Kack irgendwelche Extra-Exporter.
Man musste gucken, wo du die wieder drauf laufen lässt, weil auf dem eigentlichen
Host ist ja manchmal nicht. Da wird es dann schon ein bisschen hakelig. Geht alles,
aber man merkt Prometheus an, dass Prometheus hauptsächlich für
Applikationsmetriken gedacht ist. Und dafür ist es auch richtig gut.
SNMP ist mit vielen easy. Mit Libre, NMS und sowas ist es auch ziemlich easy.
So, und jetzt mal zu der eigentlichen Sache, warum einer Nagios geschrieben hat,
wo ich noch was zu sagen wollte. Betai Gold sagt Nagios, übrigens, wenn ich den
Namen sehe, wisst ihr, was ich immer richtig cringe finde, wie die Amis das
aussprechen? Ja, das ist ja, das ist ja ein Stern relativ nah bei uns dran. Also
nah ist, nah ist relativ gesehen. Also ist schon ein bisschen, ist 642 Lichtjahre
weg. Aber was ich richtig cringe finde, ist, wisst ihr, wisst ihr, wie die Amis
Betai Gold so aussprechen? Die sagen Beetle Shoes. Ich weiß nicht, wie die da
drauf kommen. Aber das, da cringet sich bei mir immer ein bisschen. Ja, gut, das
kenne ich, das ist nice. Ich, ich finde Uptime Robot ganz cool, wenn man
irgendwelche externen Webseiten so übermachen wird. Kostet, glaube ich,
mittlerweile auch in der Basic-Ausstattung was. Ah nee, Freeplay geht auch. So, und
jetzt zum Thema Nagios, also Monitoring-Lösung, die ich schon mal verwendet
habe. Als ich damals noch beim Provider gearbeitet habe, war ich eine Weile
zuständig für unsere Nagios-Installation. Und ich muss sagen, Nagios hat bei mir
immer noch einen Platz im Herz, ja. Dynatrace haben wir für unser Java-Zeug,
ja. Dafür muss es richtig, ähm, wie heißt dieses Ding? Ich habe vergessen, das Ding
heißt ja nicht, das hieß doch nicht, das hieß doch mal anders früher, für
Ancient One oder sowas, kann das sein? Dass es irgendwie Ancient One oder sowas
früher hieß? Ah, One-Agent. Ja, klar kann ich mich, das haben wir für unser Java,
für unseren Java-Krempel. So, und, also da habe ich mich eine Weile um unsere
Nagios-Installation gekümmert. Dementsprechend hat Nagios immer noch einen
Platz in meinem Herz. Ich mag Nagios. Was ich an Nagios mag, ist, dass Nagios
komplett konfiguriert wird über, über Config-Files und auch mit einem ziemlich
guten, da kann man sich jetzt drüber schreiben, mal so Example, ähm, ich finde
mit einem relativ guten Format. Äh, pff. Gibt's denn, ja. Ja, also ich finde ein
relativ gutes Format hat, äh, die, hat die Nagios-Config auch und die hatte damals
schon was richtig Cooles. Du konntest Nagios-Config, konntest du quasi sowas wie
Templates machen, du konntest es vererben. Du konntest quasi sagen, ja, das ist jetzt
ein Netzwerkgerät und Netzwerkgeräte kriegen standardmäßig bei mir Ping,
SNMP, Betriebssystemversion, SNMP, äh, CPU-Last, SNMP, ähm, keine Ahnung, äh,
CPU-Temperatur und sowas. Und da konntest du, da konntest du das vererben mit
Nagios und da hattest du dann quasi sowas ähnlich wie Templates. Und das Ganze
schon 2007 und 2008 rum. Also Nagios war wirklich richtig nice zur damaligen Zeit.
Mittlerweile ist Nagios ein bisschen aus der Mode gekommen. Ich persönlich finde
Nagios immer noch richtig nice. Leider ist es in der heutigen Zeit ein bisschen
aus der Mode gekommen, vor allem auch, weil es halt mit Visualisierung nicht so
dolle ist. Also die Möglichkeiten Nagios-Daten zu visualisieren, was Nagios
selbst bietet, ist ziemlich beschränkt. Ich weiß, es gibt diese, ich hab vergessen,
wie es heißt, es gibt dieses Craft-Plugin, aber wenn man das einmal mit sowas wie
Grafana vergleicht, ist vorbei. Also das ist wirklich ganz weit hinten dran.
Da kommen wir wieder dabei, man muss ein Nagios-Zeug irgendwie exportieren, dann
für Grafana oder so. Also für, ja, sehr gut.
Äh, Check-MK. Check-MK habe ich witzigerweise erst letztens ausprobiert,
mal wieder. Ähm, was mich verwirrt hat, ist die Lizenzpolitik, dass es irgendwie eine
Free-Version gibt und eine Free-Community-Version, wo man dann aber wieder nicht
alles, komisch irgendwie war das. Und es gab auch ein paar Punkte, die mir
überhaupt nicht gefallen haben, als ich da drin rumgeklickt habe und mir das
angeschaut habe. Ich kann jetzt leider aber echt nicht mal sagen, was es genau
gewesen ist. Aber ich habe es relativ schnell festgestellt, dass das nicht das
ist, was ich daheim verwenden will.
Ja, wahrscheinlich sind aber die Rechner bei dir im Wohnzimmer ein bisschen was
anderes als was dann in der Baufirma im Säuberraum läuft, oder?
Weißt du, wie man einen PM2-Restart über Button von einer Webseite ausführen
kann? Ja, man braucht eine Webseite, die PM2-Restart unter der Haube ausführt.
Also brauchst du in den Backhand, was für dich den Shell-Befehl ausführt.
So, fetten wir das, alles klar. So, und dann habe ich mir gedacht, ich gucke mir
mal wieder Zubix an. Und zwar, ich habe mir schon mal im Stream Zubix
angeguckt. Da bin ich aber nicht so richtig damit warm geworden, weil das
Zubix-Webinterface doch ziemlich eklig ist erst mal. Und ich habe aber auf der
Arbeit mal eine Weile Zubix verwendet. Das heißt, ich weiß, dass es in irgendeine
Art und Weise benutzbar sein muss, wenn man sich ein bisschen eingearbeitet hat.
Und ich habe mir auch ein paar Tutorial-Videos die letzten Tage über
angeguckt und ich glaube, ich kriege das jetzt halbwegs gebacken. Und ich habe mir
überlegt, für mich müsste Zubix daheim die beste Variante sein. Da kann ich so
simple Sachen machen, Checks, wie ich jetzt hier drinnen mache. Aber ich habe
auch ein paar, ich habe auch History und ein paar Graphen für Festplatten-Auslastung
und sowas eingebaut. Ich habe alles in einem Fleck. Ich muss kaum was selbst
bauen, was du gerade bei der Prometheus-Grafana-Kombi an einigen Stellen
musst. Da musst du dir viel selbst überlegen, wie du es denn machst. Und du hast
noch so ein paar nette Sachen dabei, wie zum Beispiel, wenn was kaputt geht, dann
kann man automatisch eine Aktion auslösen lassen, wie einen Restart oder so.
Müssen wir ausprobieren, ob ich das verwende. Aber an sich finde ich es wirklich sehr
nice. Deswegen gucken wir uns das heute mal an. Und ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher,
worauf ich es installiere. Es gibt jetzt die Möglichkeit, entweder erstmal meinen
Kodi ausmachen, der einfach nur offen war. Entweder installiere ich es auf dem
Raspberry Pi, wozu ich neige, oder ich installiere es mir hier in der VM. Aber ich
glaube, ich installiere es mir auf dem Raspberry Pi, weil da kann ich es auch
länger laufen lassen und auch mal über Nacht probieren und mal gucken, wie die
Performance ist und so. Und was ich gesehen habe, was ich mega nice fand, keine
Meinung zu PRTG. Doch, es ist Windows-only. Es sei denn, es hat sich was dran
geändert und fällt deswegen für mich raus.
Moin, hack underscore dir. Windows-only, ne, dann ist das, fällt das bei mir,
fällt das bei mir flach. Gut, dann flashen wir mal kurz die Festplatte für den
Raspberry Pi und Gutes. Jupp, komm her, Festplatte.
PIE Imager. Moment, hat er es jetzt? Hat er es jetzt
Connected überhaupt
Sandisk extrem müsste es sein was ich hier dran habe
Sandisk
2TB extreme
Yes
So hat jemand zufällig ahnung von pap
Okay
Geht so nicht wirklich
Ja, okay wenn man kann es daheim auch echt übertreiben
Wenn man monitoring system nicht mehr geht dann ist irgendwas zentrales kaputt bei mir und dann habe ich echt
Dann merke ich es auch schon
Hallo
So Raspberry Pi imager choose OS was wir jetzt was man hier dran sieht ist übrigens
Man kann mittlerweile Raspberry Pi direkt flasiert das Raspberry Pi OS direkt
Also was du machen kannst ist wenn du nicht willst dass es im chat auftaucht
Du kannst den paste bin machen und den link zum paste bin hier posten dann ist es zwar auch öffentlich
öffentlich aber wenn du den paste bin löscht ist es weg also wenn du es halt hier in chat schreibst ist halt
max kill winners
Hat man erinnere ich mich dran
Moment fuck der geht in die maus rein
Null ja so löst man so löst man sein winners 2022
Das heißt du hast checkmk extra nur dafür oder wie oder
Und was verwendest du da als alternative
So also mittlerweile sind die Raspberry Pi so advanced und das Raspberry Pi OS die können mittlerweile komplett USB boot
Das war mal eine zeit lang wo das nicht ging also man muss im prinzip nichts anderes machen wie sich beispielsweise
diesen Raspberry Pi imager holen dann sagen ja wir hätten gerne das
Minimal 64bit OS dann wählt man die SSD aus und sagt right hier kann man übrigens noch einstellen
dass man passwort und sowas und ssh enabled und sowas und dann flasht man das ganze einfach und dann ist gut dann funktioniert
So das war es ja heute machen wir es ohne wifi heute müsste das funktionieren
Was macht das da
Hallo
Wo mein
Was macht das da? Hallo? Hallo?
Hallo? Was macht der so lang?
Discarding existing data? Was gibt es da zu diskaren mann?
Was gibt es da zu diskaren, das Ding formatieren und gut ist?
Keine Ahnung. Kann der Install auch gleich Lux oder sonstige Verschlüsselung?
Das ist eine gute Frage, ich glaube nicht.
Ich glaube du nutzt das Postchamp nicht korrekt. Ich benutze Postchamp immer daraus und nach dem
Motto man wartet darauf, dass was passiert und der Ausgang ist eventuell POG. Also wir warten
darauf, dass es zum Beispiel jetzt anfängt zu zu zu reiten und das ist natürlich POG,
weil dann geht's. Sag mal, warum ist das so langsam? Oh ich hab's am USB 2 Anschluss dran. Ach so,
das erklärt's natürlich. Ich hab's am USB 2 Anschluss von meinem Rechner angeschlossen. Na gut,
dann warten wir kurz bis es geflasht ist. Feels lag mann. Das brauche ich. Das brauche
ich in meinem Board drinnen Leute. Feels lag mann. Save image. Feels lag mann. Beste. Ey,
what the fuck. Jetzt hat er aber Gas gegeben hier. Jetzt hat's geflutscht. Gatschi-Buzz.
Jetzt hatte ich gerade das Bild drinne, Leute. Jetzt hatte ich gerade das lag Bild drinne.
Yes, continue. Sync, braucht man eigentlich nicht. Gut, SSD ab und jetzt schalten wir mal
den Raspberry Pi an. Ich mache euch heute keine Kamera an. Ich glaube, den Raspberry Pi booten
haben wir jetzt, glaube ich, oft genug hier schon gesehen. Wo ist das Kabel für den Switch?
Raspberry Pi, zack. USB und das Netzteil. Netzwerkstecker, Raspberry Pi in
den Switch rein und jetzt machen wir den Raspberry Pi an. Und er sollte jetzt booten, wenn alles
funktioniert. Und ich schaue mal kurz nebenbei in meinem Router, was das Ding für eine IP
kriegt, damit ich mich dann gleich drauf connecten kann. Server leases, jawoll. Wir müssen warten,
bis der Raspberry Pi gebootet ist. Das erste Mal booten dauert ja, da muss er die Festplatte
resizen und Zeug machen. Aber er blinkt schon mal komisch. Das ist immer gut, wenn der
Raspberry Pi komisch blinkt. Per RDP? Wer zum Teufel guckt per RDP auf seinen Raspberry
Pi? Wer macht denn sowas? CacBuy. Ganz ehrlich, CacBuy brauche ich auch noch. CacBuy. Best
richtig Poggers Emote auch. Ich ist doch nur intern. Nee, ich weiß nämlich warum man das
mit RDP macht. Du kannst gucken, mit was du willst natürlich. Aber ich verstehe den Sinn
von RDP nicht. Weil man hat ja da im Prinzip eh nichts drauf, was grafisch läuft, oder?
Was meinst du? Du hast einen Desktop drauf, den du haben willst, ja? Okay, dann verstehe
ich es. Aber Mist, jetzt habe ich geguckt, was hat es für eine IP gekriegt? Raspberry
Pi. Hier. Zack. IP. SSH, Pi, Add. Yes. Raspberry sollte es sein. Okay, sehr schön. Leute,
das erste, weil es immer noch, ich zeige das so oft, weil es immer noch Leute gibt, die
das nicht wissen. Das erste, was man macht, nachdem man sich per SSH auf eine Kiste verbunden
hat, um festzustellen, ob es geht, ist SSH Copy ID. Da gibt man einmal sein Passwort ein
und jetzt muss man nie wieder sein Passwort eingeben. Da hat man nämlich das SSH Key drauf
kopiert. So, sudo minus i, install. Nee, nicht install, update. Ja, Pfeifett, Leute. Also
das ist wirklich das Beste. Müsst ihr machen. Als erstes SSH Key drauf kopieren. Ne, das
machen wir nicht rein als die Mode. Das ist eklig. Die SSD flutscht immer im Vergleich
zu der letzten. Cute. Ne, das ist nicht cute. Das ist eklig. Aber jeder, was ihm gefällt.
Okay, so, da sind wir. Installieren wir mal die üblichen Geschichten, die man so braucht.
Obwohl ich mir jetzt habe sagen lassen, die coolen Leute verwenden B-Top und nicht mehr
H-Top. Guck mal. B-Top ist anscheinend. Oder war es C-Top? Ach, keine Ahnung. Ne, das
war es anderes. Das war es anderes, was ihr meint. Jetzt habe ich B-Top. Ich meine B-Top.
Das meine ich. Aber das ist egal, weil ich verwende weiterhin H-Top. Damit kommt man
wunderbar klar. Was? G-Top? Gibt es auch nicht. Was? B-Top? Was zum Teufel? Gibt
es denn da alles? Boah, das ist nochmal Advanced oder was? Braucht doch echt kein Mensch oder?
H-Top ist Gigachat. Genau sehe ich auch so. Allein schon, bis ich B-Py-Top geschrieben
habe. Man sollte auch mal schon gecrasht. Aber seriously! Moment, Alter! Entsiste Monitoritool,
was erst mal ein Splashscreen braucht, bis es startet? Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne,
ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, Leute. Da kann es noch so gut aussehen. Nein, bestimmt nicht, garantiert
Zu dem programm kann ich nur keck beisagen
Und alle abhängigkeiten bitte gleich wieder mit entfernen
Da braucht der monitor ja mehr ressourcen also ganz ehrlich ich komme mit hart hop gut klar ich habe da keine ich brauche eigentlich nichts anderes
Was ich bei was ich bei betop ganz cool finde ist und bei den anderen dass du
noch so eine history verlauf von den cpu von der cpu auslastung das ist manchmal ganz praktisch oder von der netzweig ressourcen aber ansonsten
kommt man mit
hart hop und einem bandbreiten monitor eigentlich ganz gut ganz gut zurecht so jetzt installieren wir uns erstmal den sabbix
sabbix install raspberry pi
Na gut vielleicht können wir das einfach hier drüber
zu drüber gibt es den vielleicht schon aber wahrscheinlich gibt es den nicht im repo hier
Sabbix agent gibt es
sabbix proxy gibt es
sabbix server gibt es noch ein fünfer sabbix 5 gibt es in den in den standard das brauchen wir nicht
Sabbix 5 das outdated overrated gbeded wir brauchen das neueste download
ok lts für raspberry pi os
bullseye postgres by the way postgres weil ich habe gelesen
sabbix kann mittlerweile
timescale db
Was ich ziemlich pogg finde
Da kannst du nämlich die meisten daten die du so abrufst viel effizienter speichern
Weil monitoring daten sind zu 99 prozent
timestamp und irgendwelche values
Wir machen ja ja postgres plus engine x
nicht apache
So ok timescale setup das müssen wir uns jetzt mal anschauen wie das funktioniert
Was ist timescale db
Ich sag dir was die offiziell sagen weil die können das besser erklären dass ich das erklären kann
Wir gucken was wikipedia dazu sagt ihr könnt es noch besser erklären also timescale db gibt es gibt es auch auf deutsch
Ok timescale db ist eine open source time series datenbank
Das ist natürlich blöd weil die keine erklären was eine time series database ist gibt es auf deutsch perfekt
eine zeitreihen datenbank
Speichern oder analyse von zeitreihen wie sensoren also im prinzip lasst es mal weg
Im prinzip ist der vorteil davon du speicherst daten die quasi immer nach dem format sind
timestamp und dann irgendwelche werte
So und das ist natürlich je nachdem
Videos in der normalen datenbank speichern nichts mehr
Nachdem videos in der normalen datenbank speichern nicht sonderlich effizient da hast du ja meistens irgendwelche primary keys da kannst du ein index drauf machen
Ich habe übrigens von datenbanken wenig plan
Vielleicht auch wenn sich vielleicht anders anhört aber ich bin ich bin dem in die datenbank technisch ich kriege mit ach und krach
sql aus dem kopf hin wie ich wie ich was erstelle wie ich wie ich eine tabelle anlege wie ich den insert mache
und wie ich
ein standard mäßiges query
select quer
select wehr sonst was mehr kriege ich nicht hin kennst du volkszähler.org ja das kenne ich
Wollte ich vor ein paar jahren auch mal bauen
Hat nix hat nix mit dem census zu tun das geht um stromverbrauch messen
Im prinzip ist auch das was ich gesagt habe ein datensatz einer zeitreihen datenbank besteht aus einem
zeitstempel und einem dazugehörigen wert
Genau also das heißt nach dem monitoring daten in der regel zu 90 prozent
timeseries daten sind weil du hast ein timestamp wo was ist oder hast ein timestamp wo du was abgefragt hast das ist ein bisschen wie
influx tb genau genau oder oder wie die prometols datenbank oder sowas das ist für die für die monitoring sachen wirklich nice
damit ist die datenbank
Wahrscheinlich ein bisschen performanter aber vor allem ist die datenbank viel kleiner
Deswegen mal installieren wir das mit time times time series
Timescale db also wie installiert man denn des serbiks jetzt
Erstmal random irgendwelche sachen begetten das ist immer gut
Random sachen installieren ist auch immer gut und updaten
So weiter zappix frontend php
Zappix agent jawoll gib ihm
Yes
Ich erinnere mich daran dass zappix installation früher
Absolut krasser painz champ war mittlerweile scheint das ja ganz gut gemacht zu sein aber vielleicht haben wir einfach glück auf dem raspberry pi funktioniert es gut
Aber ja bei strikes das kenne ich
Das ist nicht folg zählung sondern folg zähler
Das ist so eine seite eigentlich ist es hauptsächlich in wiki wo gesammelt wird wie man seine strom zähler
Am besten ablesen kann plus irgendwie so ein komischer webinterface kam wollte ich mir mal vor jahren selbst bauen habe ich nie gemacht und mache ich auch nicht
installiert gedulds php 0w
Ne bevor ich das mache will ich erst mal timescale datenbank setup machen
Wir sind der timescale db extension ist already bin install ist nix already install php noch zeitgemäß ja klar
Na ja nicht wirklich
Lass mal überlegen gibt es gibt es was warum man das nicht in den container hauen will
Gut du brauchst das zappix im container läuft brauchst du mehrere container du brauchst eine datenbank du brauchst
Das frontend und du brauchst den zappix server
Aber eigentlich spricht nix dagegen das in container zu machen aber
php ist zeitgemäß ist zeitgemäß
je nachdem was du in php machst
also wenn du selbst irgendwelche session handling von hand programmierst in php dann nicht
aber wenn du sowas wie laravel zum beispiel verwendest dann ist php top und es gibt einen riesen vorteil von php
was php
meiner meinung nach
besser macht als alle anderen aber da kann php nur beschränkt was für
besser macht als alle anderen
programmiersprachen und zwar
Egal wo ihr webspace kauft
Das ding hat php support
also ihr könnt zum billigsten china chinesen house da gehen und euch dort
500 mb webspace kaufen ihr könnt eigentlich nahezu sicher sein dass das ding support für php hat und oftmals sogar noch
irgendeinen mysql dabei
php mysql ist halt quasi so der oldschool web stack den es überall gibt ja irgendein irgendein euro hosting bei
strato oder so das ding hat wahrscheinlich php und mysql
für alles andere braucht ihr entweder eine vm mit linux drauf und zum installierter selbst ja wenn ihr irgendeine rails anwendung laufen lassen wollt
irgendeine dotnet anwendung irgendeine java anwendung was auch immer da braucht ihr halt eine kiste für wo das drauf ist
und das gibt es halt normalerweise bei billig hostern nicht
oder ihr lasst halt
in irgendeinem
cloud
cluster zeug laufen die euch sagen hier einfach da
dein javascript rein stellen und dann auf die ploi drücken aber du brauchst halt eben was was drauf läuft
und das ist halt php und mysql kombi ist da halt einfach überall verfügbar
rails ist richtig nice ich mag rails hast du schon was vom smartmeter gateway gehört
keine ahnung sagt mir nix so wir sollen timescale db installieren
hatte jetzt eigentlich postcards installiert
wie heißt das package
post
version 13
ist 13 überhaupt noch aktuell genug
wer mag ruby ruby ist die beste neben neben c-sharp die beste programmiersprache die es gibt
leider ein bisschen
in der bedeutungslosigkeit verschwunden dank dem abschwung von rails quasi
13 ist ok ok also wir haben db an
ok install self-hosted timescale db und db an based systems
die installieren hier tatsächlich 14 sollte ich vielleicht auch 14 installieren
Leute ich ich ich ich ich aninstalle sekunde ich aninstalle noch mal alles was ich installiert habe
hatte jetzt auch postgres
und hat er jetzt eigentlich schon postgres installiert oder nicht
wie lässt wie wie wie wie wie ging das noch mal wie wie lässt man sich mit ab noch mal auflisten was alles installiert ist
ich meine du kannst search machen dann siehst du was es alles gibt
und dann siehst du was es alles gibt
steht hier dann auch install dahinter
was ablist minus i
okay es ist kein postgres installiert sehe ich das richtig
ein postgres install ok dann können wir das hier weiter machen dann installieren wir vielleicht einfach das 14 ein gutes also was was
soll man da machen und db an systems also
das da soll man machen nee what the fuck nein copy das war alter also das soll man machen
okay exzellent postgres client common gedöns alles klar
oh ist die große diskussion im chat ob pap gut ist oder nicht ich persönlich finde pap nicht verkehrt
pap ist jetzt nicht unbedingt das mittel meiner wahl wenn ich irgendeine neue web anwendung baue
soll aber pap hat seine vorteile und es kann durchaus sinn machen auf pap zu setzen
ja das liegt aber auch mit daran weil pap wirklich überall läuft die leute wollen sich doch guck mal
gerade kleinere unternehmen die sich irgendwie so mini webshop jetzt übrigens so witzige story und
die die den webshop sich aufsetzen wollen für irgendwas kleines die die haben billig webhosting angeboten
das ist pp-ql deswegen ist das alles in pp du kannst sowas ohne probleme in hubi in go in dotnet in was auch
immer machen in rust da kannst du in einem github projekt dabei schreiben written in rust und dann
gehst du auf hacker news und machst newspost du kannst sowas ohne probleme in hubi in go in dotnet in was
auch immer machen in rust da kannst du in einem github projekt dabei schreiben written in rust und
hacker news und machst newspost und das läuft halt darauf nicht dann brauchst du die musst du die
in eine vm holen mit linux drauf brauchst du im zweifelsfall noch einen der sich darum kümmert
es ist nicht so ich verstehe warum der kram in pap ist ja letztens hat mich jemand gefragt ob
ich ihm helfen könnte bei seinem online shop er hat einen online shop ein drop shipping ein drop
shipping online shop und er vertreibt darüber hanf da habe ich mir schon gedacht jetzt jetzt
vielleicht bewegen wir uns langsam hier in die grau zone da weiß ich nicht ob man was damit zu
tun haben will zumindest zumindest hat er gefragt ok von der hat irgendwie zwei anbieter und die
dropshippen das für ihn und ich habe ihn auch gefragt ist das illegales zeug das alles legal
also es ist nicht irgendwelches illegal angebaute zeug zumindest er hat zwei dropshipper und er
verkauft das nur über seinen shop und er möchte jetzt von den dropshippern sich eine verfügbarkeits
ein verfügbarkeits report runterladen und dann seinen shop aktualisieren ja und wie ich jetzt
darauf komme ist sein shop ist natürlich auch php könnte sogar auf wordpress basis sein und das
witzige ist die dropshipper wisst ihr in welchem format die anbieten ob produkte verfügbar sind
oder nicht du kannst in köln machen ne ne ne ne ne nicht xml es wird noch viel es wird noch
viel ähnlich schlimm ähnlich schlimm csv es ist also du machst ein köln und bekommst
ein csv aber das soll nicht genug in diesem csv ist drinnen der titel des produktes die
menge und eine produktbeschreibung und die produktbeschreibung ist html also es ist um
genau zu sein html in csv also warum auch immer man sowas baut ich habe keine ahnung warum man
das macht wo sind wir das ein stehen geblieben also ich habe das erste installiert so was soll
ich jetzt machen postgresql repository setup script a random dinger aus dem internet ausführen
ist immer poc sollte man immer machen einfach random von webseiten copy pasten ausführen
du betreust auf der arbeit mehrere stützchen die sie jetzt paints jam wir haben beispielsweise bei
uns auf der arbeit was was mit der deutschen bank fordaten synchronisiert und das ist immer noch
xml soap gedöns richtiger pains jam was ist jetzt ok geil die anleitung funktioniert schon mal nicht
von raspberry pi das ist natürlich schon mal sag jetzt habe ich ein komisches repo aktiviert
und das gibt es nicht für arm hf geil super ok wie deaktiviere ich dieses repo wieder kein
wimm installiert weird champ cringe wer kein wimm drauf hat was macht das ok das muss ich
löschen anscheinend alter wir haben maus support im wimm standardmäßig auch noch am noch an
aber wie unbrauchbar kann man es eigentlich konfigurieren synthax on und die maus weg
da ist viel besser also hier was etc absourced pg list ja weg damit wobei moment moment das
brauche ich doch noch weil kann man timescale nicht auf armen verwenden kann das sein dass
es da gar nicht drin mit funktioniert im scale den b raspberry pi geht oder habe ich hier oben
mist angeklickt raspberry pi wir machen einfach mal die anleitung weiter ich mache einfach mal
weiter keine ahnung install timescale alles klar ich führe das einfach mal sinnloserweise aus update
wird dann wieder sagen dass es nicht richtig funktioniert warum sollte es jetzt auf einmal
funktionieren und jetzt installieren das wird nicht funktionieren weil er sagt arm ist nicht
unterstützt oder doch installiert jetzt eigentlich auch in postgres ich blicke nicht mehr durch
hat jetzt hat jetzt in postgres installiert oder nicht scheint zu funktionieren timescale die
b tune sollen wir ausführen exquisite warum meckert er dann da oben dass es an das die
architektur nicht unterstützt wird obwohl es offensichtlich funktioniert ja postgres 14 hat
er installiert ok das heißt man muss da gar nichts drauf geben dass es nicht geht gut kann ich mit
leben ok was soll ich machen timescale db tun ist das korrekt yes ist das korrekt keine ahnung
yes tun memory parallelism parallelism parallelism ach du scheiße was ein wort parallelism und wall
leute wollen wir memory parallelism und wall tunen ich weiß noch nicht mal was es ist ich
ich tendiere zu jess und jess jess jess jess alles klar keine ahnung wir haben es getunet jetzt
kann nichts mehr passieren also wir haben acht gigabyte ram auf diesem raspberry pi der sollte
reichen ja ok jetzt haben wir das installiert weiter so was muss ich jetzt machen jetzt muss
ich wahrscheinlich erst mal in sehr bix weiter installieren das hatte ich schon ja ok create
initial database bäm ach nicht sudo minus u postgres enter new role password 1 2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 4
4 5 6 jawoll permission denied klar hat trotzdem funktioniert und zappichs server host und zappich
server host import das in russien die das geschrieben haben oder ich bilde mir eine zappichs
entwickler kommen irgendwie aus russland oder aus estland oder so muss mal gucken wo die herkommen
zappichs
kommen aus alexei wladisjev wladisjev ich kann das nicht richtig aussprechen wo ist
denn wo ist denn zappichs lcc wo kommen die dann her zappichs lcc brasil latvia kommen sie
her latvia was ist das lettland oder sowas was ist das auf deutsch lettland litauen irgendwie
sowas lettland alles klar keine gekommene sind das das sind letten litauer oder so wo sind
wir denn stehen geblieben also das haben wir hatte ich das schon ausgeführt ne also zbäm
ah jess was auch immer da gerade passiert er fügt er fügt dinger ein
insort eins macht er ja das ist gut zu wissen dass der so gut ist im eins insorten das könnte
der chat bestimmt noch schneller eins insorten er macht es wie ich ich copy paste immer eins und
der insort hat eins ok nice fertig next db passport nee vorher müssen wir time scale set up machen
also create extra extension ich sollte postgres neu starten gehe ich mal von aus post post
restart und jetzt time scale db aktiviert und jetzt das da ausführen alles da excellent
nicht dass ich groß durchblicken würde was passiert aber ich fühle es einfach so jetzt
müssen wir editieren etc zappix zappix server konf und dort tragen wir db password irgendwo ein also da 123456
massive secret passport jasper dankeschön für den zapp und jetzt müssen wir was konfigurieren
etc zappix nginx konf listen auf port 80 server name na gut server name wir fangen mal ganz
einfach an 168 2.13 2 war glaube ich die ip von dem ding zeigt mal ja excellent start zappix
server and agent processes machen wir wie gehst du damit um das immer weniger gerät ist ich ich
finde das doof ich habe glücklicherweise noch jede menge geräte auch die ich noch nicht im
einsatz habe aber es werden immer weniger das richtig zwischenzeitlich habe ich mal geräte
auch tatsächlich geöffnet und dort angelötet und geflasht aber es wird immer weniger weil
mittlerweile die teile oftmals gar kein esp 32 haben ich glaube die langfristige lösung ist keine
tas mutter geräte mehr zu verwenden sondern sich geräte sich geräte sind meistens auch nicht so
super teuer und lassen sich mit den gängigen sticks ansteuern da braucht es dann auch keine
custom firmware drauf restart und jetzt enable und hoffen dass es geht oder also enable ist ja
nur dass es restartet wieder so und jetzt soll man das frontend konfigurieren das war schon
die installation das war wirklich easy ich kann mich noch daran erinnern auf der arbeit hatten
sie früher richtig sich die haare aus gerupft ja beim bei der zabbix installation 1 2 3 2 1 3 2
bäm zabbix 6.0 aber ich glaube es hat einen dark mode mittlerweile niklas danke für den
zapp die geräte die geräte die preflash sind die kamen der regel aus selbst flaschen es sein es
der china selbst hersteller selbst ja aber es gibt ich habe gesehen dass es beispielsweise
deutsche shops gibt die geflashte geräte anbauen anbauen alle erst mal gärtner erst mal auf die
wiese und die tasmotor steckdose eingepflanzt aber das sind am meisten geräte man selbst selbst
flaschen kann wie meinst du das dix da wenn du in sich die stick hast ihr schon x beliebigen
sich die stick zum beispiel ein konbistick für sich b oder irgend so einen billigen drei euro
china chinesen sich b stick nein sich bs nicht alp basiert da gibt es keine cloud deswegen mache
ich mir bei sich b geräte weniger gedanken ob die nach hause nach china funken im vergleich zu
wifi geräte wifi geräte hängen in einem wlan sind alp basiert und können ins internet sich
b geräte können nicht ins internet deswegen gibt es damit china chinesen cloud auch keine
probleme erst mal wer weiß was die sich noch ausdenken in nächster zeit wer weiß wenn
dann thread und und matter und gedöns kommt war matter nicht sogar auf auf wifi basis was
ziemlich er ziemlich er paint's champ wäre also ich sehe übrigens ich bin skeptisch ob diese
thread matter geschichte überhaupt so gut ankommt wie sie sich das vorstellen was schauen
richtig ja also wenn und sich b stick hast das ist ja auch wireless funk du hängst dir nicht
an den stick also du tust ja auch das ist ja auch funk technologie sich b auf 433 ne auf 800 32
megahertz oder so sich b ist 2,4 genau sich b ist auf dem gleichen wie altes wlan stimmt so
war das irgendwie genau genau du brauchst du brauchst den sich b stick und dann brauchst du
in home assistant add-on oder du verwendest home assistant selbst die haben ja mittlerweile
auch ganz gute sich b integration reicht in stick weiter und es funktioniert so also installation
ist durch also die fort language englisch your most choice jaja passt checking prerequisites
alles klar das ist halt so typisches php zeug da habe ich immer keine ahnung was es mir sagen
soll php option arc separator output und required und cool story pro alles klar jetzt weiß man
bescheid konfigure db connection password 1 2 3 4 5 6 next step zabbik server name da ist
einfach nur zabbik default theme dark blue high contrast dark leute dark theme oder light theme
was sagt ihr ich kenne euch ihr sagt dark theme weil das ist hacker man chat minus eins
ich habe auch sich b2m qtt ja habe ich auch europe plus zwei afrika europe berlin ich kann ihnen
stick pf ich kann ihnen stick empfehlen nämlich den ich auch habe den kombi stick der ist gut
der kostet aber ein bisschen mehr als der 8 euro china stick aber da funktioniert
ok leute wir machen erstmal wir gucken ob das light theme was taugt ja was trinken muss ich richtig
so next next und jetzt fertig
zabbik default login enter user name admin mit password zabbik alles klar admin ich schreibe
das genauso wir testen es mal klein ob das auch funktioniert zabbik ernsthaft das ist case
sensitive zabbiks what the fuck
ah irgendwelche language sachen sind nicht installiert
was will er von mir haben language for local for local for language
enable to translate das ist mir scheiß egal du kannst es ruhig auf englisch lassen weiß
das ist gut das kann ich mir nämlich aus dem kopf nicht merken können konfigure wobei
der standardmäßig doch eigentlich auf en us stehen sollte oder was oder pie recipe config
vielleicht language system options als dpga g-3 konfigure kann man nicht ja auch einfach
language einstellen ihr lokale en ach nee en gb ist es standardmäßig nee ok en us warum
haben die warum warum haben die zwei sachen egal ich zähle mal bei dass man weiß ja nie
und das auch geben wobei das sollte eigentlich reichen oder ok default en us keine benachrichtigung
auf dem discord kam keine was ist da warum warum nicht hätte eigentlich hätte eigentlich
kommen müssen ok restart mal gucken ob es jetzt besser geht prager das sieht auch schon
besser aus wie macht man das eigentlich mit einem haumas ist das ganz entscheidend von
der sd karte ab also machs wie ich nehme der ssd das ist der ssd zahndisk extrem in dem
fall usb ssd du kannst aber auch eine ssd du kannst aber auch eine sd karte nehmen samsung
endurance zum beispiel das ist quasi ssd flash in sd karten weiß nicht ob man das wirklich
so sagen kann aber die sind deutlich haltbarer damit musst du dir auch keine gedanken machen
aber von der performance her ist natürlich eine ssd umlängeln besser als die mikro sd
x austin prime ach nee x autist prime danke für den sub 12 monate massive subscription
alles klar so so wie das habe ich starrmäßig aus so ich habe mir folgende sachen überlegt
was wir ausprobieren können um zu zu paar haus zu checken also das erste was wir machen
ist mein linux tv receiver checken dort habe ich schon in weißer voraussicht ein prometoys
note exporter laufen weil ich den sub x h nicht zum laufen bekommen habe das ist ein tv receiver
und kein vollständiger linux host dann habe ich zum überwachen mir überlegt wir nehmen
die steckdose im bad wir nehmen noch mal ein schild tv wir nehmen zertifikatsstatus noch
von meinem wiki mal gucken wie das funktioniert wie gut man damit klarkommt also einzige sache
die ich bisher von zabbix mir gemerkt habe ist dass das interface etwas etwas pains champ
ist aber ich habe mir ein paar tutorials angeguckt die letzten paar tage das heißt ich glaube
ich habe es jetzt halb halbwegs gecheckt also was man sieht zabbix ist eine monitoring lösung
mit der man selber überwachen kann und sich benachrichtigen lassen kann oder übersicht
hat wenn irgendwas nicht so funktioniert wie es funktionieren soll standardmäßig ist
hier testweise plus der zabbix selber drinnen wenn man hier auf haus guckt guckt plus der
zabbix selber den lassen wir auch mal drinnen jetzt fügen wir mal die anderen haus hinzu
ist das immer noch so dass zabbix nicht agentless ist du kannst das beides machen du kannst
zabbix agent installieren du kannst snmp verwenden oder du kannst auch gar keinen agent verwenden
dann kannst du halt keine checks mit dem agent ausführen aber du kannst zum beispiel mittlerweile
prometheus sachen direkt verarbeiten angeblich habe ich gelesen probieren wir gleich mal
aus also man kann wohl noch prometheus nodexporter direkt in zabbix integrieren mittlerweile oder
du kannst einfach SSH checks oder sowas machen oder pingen vom server ohne agents sehen wir
jetzt gleich ich habe auch keinen großen plan davon also so ich würde sagen wir fangen
mal an mit der linux mit dem linux tv tuner zum um den zu überwachen so ip add das ding
hat diese ip so und was ich gelesen habe ist folgendes nicht gelesen stimmt nicht was
ich in dem was ich in den tutorial videos gesehen habe ist folgendes der hostname muss
einzigartig sein der visible name nicht also als hostname kann man entweder die ip nehmen
und dann da sowas wie vu plus oder so hinschreiben oder vu plus oder irgendwas ja oder man denkt
sich hier irgendwas einzigartiges aus habe ich in dem habe ich im tutorial so gehört
und also groups muss man auswählen groups kann man auch kann man einfach auch nichts
auswählen weil ich will nicht linux auswählen wenn ich linux server auswähle fragt er bestimmt
30.000 dinger ab standardmäßig wir sagen einfach mal das sind virtual machines oder
macht er nichts wenn ich linux server auswähle wenn wir gleich sehen wenn er auf einmal ganz
viele sachen darauf checkt dann mache ich linux server wieder raus ok ip so und dann
habe ich noch noch was gesehen in einem tutorial video man kann hier unten interfaces hinzufügen
das ist entweder ein subx agent snmp ein management interface oder java krempe ich habe hierauf
auf meinem linux tv fernseh receiver habe ich keinen subx agent ich habe mir von alpine
linux den armen subx agent mal drauf kopiert ich weiß aber gar nicht ob ich den verwenden
will weil ich habe hier eigentlich einen prometoys nord exporter drauf laufen das ist ein statisches
go binary was einfach überall funktioniert und den würde ich jetzt versuchen da mal
zu integrieren müssen wir mal schauen so also linux server kann man sonst noch hinzufügen
die description braucht kein mensch interfaces ja interfaces füge ich trotzdem mal hinzu
weil ich gelesen habe wenn ich gelesen habe sage ich meine tutorial videos geguckt weiß
ich warum ich sag gelesen der versucht dann ein subx agent auf diesem server zu erreichen
das ist aber nicht schlimm wenn er das nicht kann der verwendet die ip die hier eingetragen
ist aber wohl noch für mehr sachen als für den subx agent also sollte man vielleicht
wobei wir lassen zwar weg wir lassen zwar weg und gucken was dann passiert ok et ok nice
jetzt haben wir neuen server angelegt für den es nichts gibt jetzt versuchen wir mal
ob wir den server wenigstens pingen können einfach gucken ob der server ab ist so da
gibt es bestimmt ein fertiges template für hingen oh sechs seiten templates kann man
in den settings vielleicht einstellen wie viele seiten ich standardmäßig angezeigt
bekomme ok refresh kann man einstellen autologin autologin dark blue default rose per page
vielleicht keine ahnung 1000 weil ich habe keinen bock alles immer ausklappen zu müssen
vielleicht ist es rose per page ja sehen wir gleich templates ja wunderbar ping icmp ping
das ist gut genau das will ich haben icmp ping icmp ping ping gibt standardmäßig ich
habe linux ich habe kein linux template ausgewählt ich habe gesagt linux host group also man
bekommt packet loss also einer nicht wirklich packet loss ping loss ping ob ab oder dauernd
response time zurück ok also macht man das jetzt items aha hier templates ping icmp
und die host group ist das die logik verstehe ich jetzt nicht wirklich was wer hat sich
das web interface ausgedacht host group template ok und jetzt sollten wir den ping bekommen
nein wir bekommen keinen ping weil cannot find host interface alter du kack noob der
name ist der name ist die ip alter ich muss doch ein interface hinzufügen das ist doof
gemacht da kann ich mich dran erinnern das hat mich das letzte mal schon irritiert jetzt
muss ich jetzt muss ich so tun als hätte das ding ein interface mit einem subx agent obwohl
da überhaupt kein subx agent drauf läuft das ist doch richtig dumm oder ich meine
man könnte das template wahrscheinlich anpassen dass das template auf den host namen geht
und nicht auf die interface ip aber an den an den subx ja das template braucht das ja
das icmp template braucht die ip wohl ein bisschen bescheuert ist es schon oder nicht
sonderlich intuitiv muss man sagen aber sag mal so ich könnte das jetzt im template ändern
oder aber die ip ja aber hoffentlich kein dedizien nee ich glaube den agent braucht
man nicht ich glaube man muss nur die ip hier angeben und es ist egal ob ein agent darauf
läuft oder nicht das habe ich zumindest in dem tutorial so gesehen der nimmt sich die
ip vom ersten agent für diese standard checks was natürlich ein bisschen doof ist weil
jetzt muss ich da den agent angeben den es eigentlich gar nicht gibt schon blöd oder
egal machen wir mal update das funktioniert jetzt ok jetzt haben wir hier unseren host
items und drei trigger trigger sind quasi alarme im subx und es gibt alarme für wenn
die response zeit zu hoch ist wenn es zu viel ping loss gibt oder wenn der server down ist
so das heißt ich sollte jetzt unter host latest data nee ping nee der hat den glaube ich
noch nicht gecheckt kann das sein nee hat noch nichts hat noch nichts gecheckt was ist
der standard intervall wieder seine checks laufen lässt man konnte hier doch irgendwie
den kram neu checken lassen services monitoring host ich glaube die das prtg intuitiver ist
aber prtg ist bei mir ich wenn es es das für linux gibt würde ich das wahrscheinlich
mir auch mal angucken aber ich sehe es nicht ein wie eine windows kiste hinzustellen dass
ich dann mein monitoring darüber machen kann außerdem ist es glaube ich lizenz technisch
auch nicht so ohne und subx ist halt komplett kostenlos open source die gleiche version
die man auch kaufen kann also kaufen du sie im endeffekt den support so und macht er jetzt
was latest data hey funktioniert guck mal last check vor 34 sekunden last value 0% der host
ist ab und die response prometheus machen wir gleich wir wir nutzen den ich habe hier
auf meinem linux receiver den prometheus node exporter laufen und der angeblich angeblich
kannst du den node exporter mittlerweile direkt im subx integrieren subx muss halt wohl wirklich
saumäßig flexibel sein was es frisst du kannst mit subx wohl alles irgendwie so processen
dass man es verarbeiten kann aber prometheus haben sie jetzt wohl direkt eingebaut ok so
jetzt haben wir die response zeit das heißt wir sehen hier bei dem host das subx nicht
available ist ok interface ist nicht da so was habe ich jetzt irgendwie eine ordentliche
übersicht oder so davon problems gibt es nicht ok haus und wo habe ich jetzt irgendwie gescheite
übersicht zu dem host weil ok ich sehe der host hat keine probleme das ist ja das ja
schon mal gut aber ich kann mir den graf angucken von response time ach hier kurz hier sieht
man jetzt die response time vom ping kann man ran zoomen kann sich angucken aha massive
ping spike von 0,02 millisekunden um 16 36 wahrscheinlich müsste ich jetzt in den dashboard
anlegen für den host ja und ist es pains champ weiß ich noch nicht so genau was gibt
es denn hier unter reports triggers top 100 nichts ja gut es hat ja auch nichts getriggert
availability report icmp alles in ordnung top pocket ok latest data werde ich nie reingucken
das ja komplett overkill hier gibt es auch nichts hier gibt es auch nichts also im prinzip
guckt man sich das dann wahrscheinlich hier an und solange hier keine probleme stehen
ist alles gut irgendwie hätte ich gerne kennt noch einer das den nagios overview wo alles
grün war bis es rot wurde das fand ich eigentlich cool das da guckt mal sowas sowas hätte ich
gerne hallo darf ich das anklicken sowas sowas hätte ich gerne leute ich möchte eine
liste haben mit haus und ok dahinter wenn er pinkt wird keine craft ich will einfach
eine tabelle haben mit ist ab ist daun zumindest zumindest als übersicht mal wenn ich das tv
ausmache dann gibt es probleme ja aber ich will ja eine übersicht haben das kann man
sich hier bestimmt zusammen wurschteln mit dem mit mit dashboards host availability gut
diesen krempel brauche ich das ist crap es gibt keine probleme das ist schon mal gut
zu wissen alles in ordnung poc topics information braucht kein mensch problems gibt es nicht
so neues gadget was haben wir hier zu bieten action lock ist leer geil glock discovery status
crafts geomap crafts host pattern jetzt was ok ich weiß nicht was ich hier mache übrigens
ja gut das ist jetzt für ein host übersicht das ist blödsinnig was gibt es denn sonst
noch so problem haus den ich habe keine problem top host was auch immer top haus sind haus
groups linux server what the fuck nee was add alter das ist ja mal alles andere als
intuitiv item ok ping name näher ping halt jetzt kann man angeben ab wann das in welche
farbe bekommt ok das ist tatsächlich gar nicht schlecht kann man jetzt noch den namen
hinzu haus name dunkel dran erinnern dass das so funktioniert habe ich nämlich schon
mal gesehen so ok jetzt hat man übersicht ob die haus ab oder daun sind das finde ich
schon mal sehr nice so was hätte ich gerne und jetzt wenn es geht wenn es geht noch mit
mit farbe und noch ein paar mehr infos später aber ich will einfach so eine ganz auf ich
will auf meinem dashboard wenn ich mich einlogge einfach eine ganz simple übersicht ist ab
oder ist daun und dann kann ich mir die problems angucken wenn was daun ist ich will einfach
im ersten blick sehen bärm ab oder daun so und es kann man doch jetzt bestimmt einfärben
so base color ist grün weil weil base color ist ja ab so und jetzt sagen wir ihm thresholds
ach so ich brauche jetzt erstmal was was ich da was daun geht ja null oder oh nee jetzt
ist es rot kakuei nee nee nee nee so funktioniert das nicht ok leute ich brauche erst mal was
ab und daun gehen kann dass ich das dass ich das ausprobieren kann oder ich muss sagen
base color oder ich muss sagen base color rot base color rot und ab eins ist es grün das
muss ich sagen dann funktioniert ok leute wir brauchen noch einen anderen host den ich
ab und daun machen kann so save und ok wir legen noch einen anderen host an zum testen
zum testen machen wir mal folgendes if config aber wie heißt meine mein interface hier
auf der dienungskiste ens 33 natürlich alles klar warum nicht die kafana und prometos
habe ich aktuell am start und das habe ich vor einer weile abgelöst durch so eine minimalistische
geschichte nehme ich durch sowas hier wobei die mir zu minimalistisch ist erstens will
ich da noch mehr reinpacken und zweitens ist das sag mal mal so zu 70 80 prozent ok aber
ich hätte gerne noch so sachen wie festplatten auslastung und sowas und das machst mit ab
time kuma nicht so und ich will irgendeine lösung wo alles in einem ist ich habe ich
habe lange auch daheim prometos und kafana verwendet und du kannst zwar alles machen
mit prometos und kafana also kannst du kannst den black box exporter verwenden du kannst
den ns den snmp exporter verwenden aber ich finde man merkt prometos einfach an dass es
für metric einsammeln gedacht ist und nicht für so klassisches host ab und daun monitoring
und ich finde die gesamt lösung irgendwie charmant dass du im topics alles machen kannst
was du machen willst also von prometos sachen abfragen der kann ja mittlerweile quasi note
exporter verarbeiten das probieren wir gleich mal aus habe ich noch nie gemacht und ich
glaube dass das für mich daheim so als als gesamt lösung das beste ist prometos muss
ich mir auch viel oder gerade kafana muss ich mir auch viel selber stricken wobei ich
gelesen habe dass das neue unify alerting oder wie das unified alerting was es bei kafana
gibt wohl einiges verbessert hat zumindest was ja so schwellwerte und sowas angeht das
habe ich aber noch nicht ausprobiert ja und nachdem ich keine application metriken daheim
einsammeln will sondern einfach nur gucken ist ab daun port auf zu einsammeln festplatten
speicher und dann warnen wenn es unter zehn prozent geht oder sowas glaube ich ist die
bessere universal kombi und was ich tatsächlich bei zappings ganz cool finde dass man sogar
actions auslösen kann wenn was daun geht ich brauche zwar wahrscheinlich nicht aber
die idee dahinter finde ich eigentlich nice da könnte ich nämlich zum beispiel sagen
weil zum beispiel der mqtt server den ich im internet stehen habe wo ich meine mein
location tracking von meinen mobile geräten drüber mache das ding verschluckt sich regelmäßig
beim reloaden von letzten kripp zertifikaten also es reloadet einfach nicht obwohl es einmal
nachts per grondschopf angeblich reloadet und wenn ich ins loch kucke sagt er auch dass
er reloaded hat aber der interessiert sich nicht für das neue zertifikat und was man
dann hin was man dann machen muss ist man muss sich darauf einloggen aus irgendwelchen
gründen den zertbord noch mal starten und dann noch mal reloaden keine ahnung und das
könnte ich beispielsweise über eine action machen wenn das zertifikat ausläuft klingt
ganz gut mal gucken auf der anderen seite ist es nicht schlecht wenn ich wenn ich beide
seiten kenne wie gesagt wo meter ist grafana hat ich eine weile daheim wir haben relativ
viel auf der arbeit was das angeht auch gerade die ganzen cloud kisten und auch viel von
unseren anwendungen also unser ganzes java anwendungs zeug und sowas ist da drin
ne kupa ne das habe ich nicht daheim habe ich auch nicht vor habe ich keinen wirklichen
anwendungszweck außer halt zum basteln und üben wäre das natürlich was so also wo sind
wir stehen geblieben was wollte ich jetzt machen aber ich wollte eine extra ip auf mein auf
mein interface legen also aktuell haben wir hier was habe ich für eine ip 192.182.127
dann machen wir jetzt einfach mal if konfig hoffentlich kriege ich das aus dem kopf hin
ich weiß manche leute sagen jetzt max nehmen noch ip ich habe keine ahnung wie man das
mit ip macht aus dem kopf ein zweites interface ins 1 1 9 2 1 2 2 punkt keine ahnung 69 slash
24 ab so jetzt müsste ich eine zweite ip haben auf meinem auf meinem interface hier
guck mal 2 ips habe ich jetzt ok das erste ist wahrscheinlich für address und das zweite
ist wahrscheinlich für add gehe ich mal von aus da wird immer abgekürzt was das zeug
hält ist eigentlich auch einfach zu merken aber ich habe mir vor jahren irgendwie mal
das ganze if konfig zeug gemerkt und ich ich tu mir halt schwer dabei zu sagen ja ich mache
das jetzt mit dem anderen wenn ich bei dem anderen nicht weiß wie es geht also wenn
ich die auswahl habe zwischen ich tippe jetzt einfach das ein was ich weiß oder ich gucke
nach wie das mit dem anderen geht wait du hast jetzt eine netzwerkarte mit zwei ips ja das
ist kein ding das geht du kannst dem ding auch ich weiß nicht wo das ip limit ist ich würde
jetzt mal sagen 4096 kein schimmer das geht ja das geht unter windows auch also du kannst
beliebig viele ips auf eine netzwerkarte binden musstest du früher zum beispiel auch bei
sachen wie tv headend und uns hat ip die haben immer nur ein stream über einen interface
gemacht weil sie pepega waren im kopf mittlerweile nicht mehr so also jetzt haben wir eine zweite
ip und die monitoren wir jetzt mal und schauen wie das funktioniert jetzt wenn ich das ab
und down mache also create host hostname test host templates templates in bekommt das groups
linux server interfaces ja die ip ist schon absichtlich agent ich habe kein agent aber
machen wir trotzdem weil das dämlich ist mit dem ip check so test host und was haben
wir jetzt gelernt wir gehen auf items markieren das und sagen execute now und dann spammen
wir so oft latest data bis was erscheint bis er gepinkt hat du kannst auch ganze subnetz
an ein interface binden mit any ip 5 header time ja man kann viel machen falls man fragen
zu pvp hat kann man diese bei allgemein einfach ein posten wenn du fragen zu pvp hast dann
ist wir haben ein programmiert channel da ist irgendwie progress hilfe oder so da kannst
es rein posten aber wie gesagt du kannst auch ein pace bin machen und ich kann mal hier
im stream kurz reingucken ich habe keinen großen plan von pvp aber vielleicht ist es
ja einfach ja code pen geht auch wobei wer weiß was für ein code pen ich dann aufmache
vielleicht vielleicht ist in dem code pen dann irgendwie den image hentai drin oder
so ich trau ich trau dem chat alles zu ok hat gepinkt wunderbar der host ist ab dashboard
test host ist ab ok und jetzt gucken wir mal ob der test host gleich daun ist wie stellt
man eigentlich den check intervall ein das muss ich mir noch mal kurz angucken code
pen ok ich mach mal kurz auf dein code pen also ok der sinn warum man das jetzt unbedingt
in dem code pen posten wird erschließt sich mir nur am rande aber ok ja und was willst
du jetzt wissen also ich will bilder in meinem html form hinzufügen diese per pvp abschinken
das ok zu der pvp seite kann ich dir nicht wirklich helfen aber ach so du machst das
einfach mit einem normalen input ja gut gut du bräuchst jetzt noch ein submit knopf dafür
da also wenn du normalen input verwenden willst musst du das in der form machen und du brauchst
ein submit knopf dass er den request überhaupt schickt ne von der pvp seite habe ich keine
ahnung in dotnet könnte ich dir das zeigen wie man das macht in asp dotnet code das
wäre eine sache von zwei minuten aber in pvp in pvp keine ahnung kein schimmer das weiß
ich nicht so also down ip und jetzt sollte das gar ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja
ging das nicht so
if config down interface ja ja ja dass man das mit dem anderen machen kann ist aber ging
das ging das nicht mit einfach interface down echt nicht na gut gut dann machen wir das so
easy zack ja ja 69 was aber moment habe ich das schon jetzt gelöscht ah ich depp das
erste mal hat es doch schon funktioniert die ip ist schon längst weg es hat schon längst
funktioniert das erste mal hat schon geklappt null ok ich habe nichts gesagt hat funktioniert
ok alles klar so jetzt sollte das jetzt sollte der eigentlich down sein gleich beim der host
ist down jawoll wo stellt man den intervall ein wie oft er solche checks macht bei items
vielleicht icmp ping update intervall eine minute naja eine minute ist eigentlich ganz
schön lang oder auf der anderen seite ich mein eigentlich auch wiederum kurz genug also
ich glaube das kann man durchaus auf eine minute lassen gut und jetzt sollte er nicht
nur anzeigen dass der host down ist sondern er sollte eigentlich auch problems anzeigen
warum zeigt er keine problems an der host ist down
allgeblich hat er auch einen problem der host available bei icmp jetzt kann es sein dass
die aktualisierung für problems erst nach zwei fehlschlägen oder so das kann sein dass
die eingestellt haben das muss zwei bis drei mal fehlschlagen dass es überhaupt erst als
problem durchgeht das müssen wir sich mal anschauen was wie das wie das konfiguriert
ist also host trigger ja es müssen dreimal ich glaube das bedeutet das es müssen die
letzten drei fehlschlagen haben dass es auf failed geht naja gut aber bei einem ping also
bei einem ping könnte man durchaus sagen schon beim ersten mal anschlagen okay null
boah das hätte ich ja nie gedacht so und jetzt kriege ich die nachricht ein ich habe
ein alert problems habe ich auch am start recent problems das operational data erkennt
hier mal den unterschied
ach hier down ja ok also das unavailable bei ping down ist da wäre ich auch so noch drauf
gekommen ehrlich gesagt ok ans interface muss man sich wirklich erst gewöhnen die
ganzen text jucken mich mal absolut gar nicht kann man den kram und text brauche ich ja
schon viel übersichtlicher ok wunderbar so und jetzt mal das ding wieder an das blinken
das blinkt glaube ich nur 30 sekunden oder so wenn es neu ist das ist für den fall gemacht
dass wenn man das auf der monitor wand hat in irgendeinem operation center dass dann
halt auffällt dass was passiert ist ok wir machen jetzt ab wir legen die ip ab wir machen
die ip wieder rauf und jetzt sollte der nach einer minute je nachdem wann der checkt warum
habe ich eigentlich keine uhr mit aber ja mit anuhr jetzt sollte danach jetzt bis eine
minute eigentlich wieder auf grün gehen default intervall alle 10 sekunden refreshen guck
mal jetzt schon wieder ab da ist er also das funktioniert schon mal ganz passabel einfach
sagen ab und down problems können wir gucken und jetzt steht hier ok ist wieder ist wieder
resolved ist ok history warum sehe ich jetzt nicht wo es angefangen hat kaputt zu gehen
also ich hätte jetzt mit history hätte ich eigentlich erwartet dass ich sehe da ist es
kaputt gegangen und jetzt geht es wieder ach so ach so ist das gemacht oh das ist ja das
ist doch doof warum kann man denn eine timeline timeline schauen ich hätte erwartet es gibt
einen eintrag für für problem und dann für recover oder warum ist das warum ist das in
einer in einer linie das ist erstmal unverständlich show timeline ne ne das hatte ich gerade schon
das macht es nicht ja gut da muss man sich muss man sich dran gewöhnen denke ich dann
ist ok normalerweise hat man das ja auch nicht ausgeklappt sondern so dann aktualisiert das
alle 10 sekunden so wenn man es dann genau wissen will wenn ich das jetzt richtig interpretiert
wenn man es dann wo war ich denn jetzt gerade monitoring problems ja ist sorry so wenn ich
das jetzt richtig interpretieren dann kann ich jetzt da drauf und mir sogar die history
anzeigen lassen genau und hier sieht man jetzt ganz genau wann das gewesen ist kann
man ran zoomen das ist naja also dass der ping kraft interpoliert ist fragwürdig ja
ich meine das ist höchstwahrscheinlich eher so und ich so es ist nicht so dass der ping
auf einmal 0,6 war um 16 52 30 das müsste eigentlich eher der ping war weg hier war
Schrödingers ping genau planst du auch einen desktop client zu verwenden ne also was ich
machen werde als notifications ist wie heißt das ich habe keine ahnung wie es heißt ja
home assistant home assistant push notifications ich weiß gar nicht wie heißt das nicht könnte
sogar es könnte einfach sowas könnte home assistant push notifications das heißt wahrscheinlich
einfach home assistant push notifications ja genau die notify funktion aus home assistant
will ich verwenden ich habe nämlich die home assistant app bei mir auf dem handy und ich
schicke einfach an die api das muss ich mal gucken weil ich glaube nicht dass es im zappig
standardmäßig integriert ist ich schicke an meine home assistant api dann die die sachen
kriege ich aufs handy krieg ich eine push notification dann brauche ich kein pushover
pushover habe ich früher mal verwendet aber pushover kostet halt pro gerät wenn ich das
richtig im hinterkopf habe es kann auch sein dass push bullet war ich bin mir nicht mehr
ganz sicher da musst du quasi pro gerät einmal bezahlen ja weiß nicht so teuer aber
das schon ok und die home assistant app die funktioniert auch wenn man unterwegs ist
obwohl man nicht mal vpn eingeloggt ist pushover ist free wirklich muss man nicht die muss
man nicht bezahlen pro app pro gerät ja sage ich doch fünf dollar one time purchase das
geht mit home assistant ja 5 dollar one time gottify kann kein ios das kann kein ios ok
du hast recht nicht pro gerät pro account pro account ja du hast recht nicht pro gerät
pushover hat irgendwie ein paar probleme gerade ja im prinzip pro platform dann ja also pro
account also einmal mit seinem ios account ich mein 15 euro ganz ehrlich für wenn du
wirklich alles drei verwendet das ist durchaus gerechtfertigt und fair da kannst du nichts sagen
pushover ist irgendwie rip oder auch nicht aber ios gibt es nicht gottify ist komplett
android only oder oder post jam oder chat letztes mal als geguckt da war das nur android
ja ja ja das ist nur ist ja so und mit der home assistant app ist es so dass das notification
auch funktioniert ich hoffe ich erzähle jetzt keinen totalen mist aber ich habe ja selbst
ios ich habe selbst ios notification über was nutt notify.sh kannst du ist das dein service
simono ich hab dich noch nie im chat gesehen vielleicht ist ja dein service also ich sage
das so weil das wäre nicht das erste mal dass wir leute im chat haben die zufälligerweise
werbung machen für ihren eigenen service was ich nicht schlimm finde in dem fall ja also
kannst du ich sagen wenn wer das von dir ist so android ios f droid ios ios iphone download
das ist jebait das ist jebait die anderen überhaupt kein ios release alter jebait im
chat mann geil alter krasser jebait es gibt keine ios app geil massive jebaited
ach doch moment es gibt ne app oder hat die nicht auf seiner webseite verlinkt ok das
ist das ist das ist blöd weil naja ich weil okay die müssen den kram unbedingt auf der
home page verwenden wann nächstes video ich brauche ein gutes thema für nächstes
video dann gibt's nächstes video warum ist der app store eigentlich überall so ab langsam
außer unter safari unter ios warum apple warum das gibt es ergibt doch keinen sinn das hat
doch keinen grund warum das so langsam sein muss ja oder was heißt safari und warum das
unter unter anderen betriebssystem als merck langsam ist ich habe das schon öfters gemerkt
wenn ich das erste mal den app store aufmache ist es übelst langsam so ok die app sieht
nicht schön aus aber das ist egal so lange sie funktioniert ist ja alles gut ja nice
ja aber zurück zu home assistant soweit ich das bei mir mitbekommen habe funktioniert
home assistant und notifications auch wenn du nicht per vpn drinne bist weil die notifications
gehen ja nicht etwa von deinem home assistant server an deine home assistant app die notifications
gehen per push notifications über apple weil es der einzige weg ist video unter ios push
notifications schicken kann anders geht nicht das muss über apple gehen und dementsprechend
registriert sich deine app mit irgendeinem frag mich nicht callback link bei apple und
dementsprechend geht das auch über die ios app wenn man weil man diese gleiche all die
auch im public lte netz hat dann funktioniert das auch wenn man nicht per vpn eingeloggt
ist bei android ist es je nachdem wie du es verwendest bei android kannst du notifications
auslösen auch ohne über google zu gehen aber du kannst sicherlich auch unter android push
notifications empfangen über public server und das gibt bestimmt auch aber habe ich
sie aus dem thema feier war was für ein ding feier waller war was war das habe ich nicht
mitbekommen feier waller feier waller purple review der name wird mich schon abschrecken
nee die push notifications gehen ohne cloud also ich müsste das noch mal testen also
bevor ich jetzt sage ja hundertprozentig das geht waller alter waller bevor ich jetzt
sage hundertprozentig das geht also was ich dir sagen muss ich das noch mal explizit
ausprobieren nehme ich das wlan ausschalten weil ich bekomme zum beispiel eine notification
wenn es hoftor auf und zu geht und so was und weil das geht eigentlich auch wenn ich
nicht im wlan bin aber auf nummer sicher zu gehen muss ich explizit mal das wlan ausschalten
demnächst also was ich dir sagen kann ist push notifications gehen definitiv wenn man
nicht registriert es mit der home assistant cloud auf nummer sicher zu gehen dass sie
auch ohne wlan gehen müsste ich jetzt noch mal ausprobieren aber ich bin mir sehr sehr
sicher eigentlich aber ich müsste das nächste mal einfach mal links wifi ausschalten übrigens
ich muss euch was zeigen was ihr unter ios unbedingt unbedingt ausschalten müsst wenn
ihr ein iphone habt ich muss bloß gerade mal kurz schauen wie der kempel wie der kempel
hieß
der cloud backup auch ihr müsst unbedingt ausschalten ah fuck ich finde es jetzt nicht
also man kann unter ios da ist standardmäßig eingeschaltet dass wenn man in dem wlan ist
dass der wifi assist oder sowas macht hieß das glaube ich wlan unterstützungen die aktivieren
ja das da ich weiß nicht wie es aktuell heißt aber so ähnlich diesen crap muss man ausmachen
weil den ich wifi assist ja doch genau diesen crap muss man ausmachen weil sobald man oder
besser gesagt sobald also wofür es gedacht ist ganz einfach wenn man verbunden ist mit
einem schrott access point der im bits pro sekunde quasi nur hinbekommt dann kannst
du parallel zum wlan über die mobilverbindung noch zusätzlich laden was natürlich ziemlich
fragwürdig ist weil wenn man im wlan ist wenn man übers wlan gehen so bei mir ist es
jetzt so dass ios wenn ich auf der terrasse bin der meinung ist die verbindung zu deinem
access point die ist aber ganz schlecht obwohl ich noch irgendwie 40 mbit 40 mbit bekomme
ja also man kann jetzt nicht sagen dass 40 mbit über wlan irgendwie schlecht sind und
selbst wenn ich ganz am rand bin bekomme ich noch 5 bis 15 mbit das reicht vielleicht
nicht aus um hd videos zu streamen über youtube aber was ansonsten passiert ist die schalten
das um von wlan auf mobilfunk und das will ich ja gar nicht ich will nicht von mobilfunk
von wlan auf mobilfunk umgeschaltet werden weil ich bin zum beispiel auf internen seiten
in meinem wlan ja ich bin zum beispiel in meiner heim automatisierung im wlan und ich
will nicht dass ich laufend rausgeschmissen werde ins ins ins mobile netz also diesen
müll muss man ausschalten seitdem ich das ausgeschaltet habe bekomme ich ohne probleme
wunderbar verbindung weil er eben nicht sagt so schlecht ich gehe jetzt raus ich will wlan
nicht ausmachen ich will ja auf internet services zugreifen die es nur über mein wlan gibt
seit ich das ausgeschaltet habe habe ich wunderbar verbindung komplett bis zum garteneingang
im wlan überhaupt kein problem und vorher war ios immer so so vorauseilen hat gesagt
nein nein nein nein die wlan verbindung ist so schlecht die muss ich jetzt abbrechen und
jetzt machen wir aber das macht er jetzt nicht mehr also das ist top worst funktion überhaupt
macht bestimmt bei manchen leuten sind ich finde es einfach nur nervig und es kommt einem
das wlan was man daheim hat viel schlechter vor wenn man diese funktion eingeschaltet
hat als es eigentlich ist weil es sich immer rauskickt obwohl es sich gar nicht rauskicken
müsste so also wo sind wir jetzt stehen geblieben beim beim zebix meine host sind ab prege da
bin ich ja froh dass meine host ab sind also wir haben jetzt schon mal festgestellt das
funktioniert was kann man hier eigentlich noch so einstellen bei top hosts da bringt
es jetzt nicht bei up und down ist halt up und down machen wir mal so kann man noch mehr
bei man könnte die problem so alter ich gehe mal fort da habe ich da habe ich auch schon
also da ist halt krafana einfach superior was so was angeht so safe changes ok wunderbar
jetzt hat man die ganzen kram jetzt hat man schönen überblick über host prinzipiell
und dann wenn es probleme gibt glaub damit kann ich ganz gut leben favorite maps das
brauche ich garantiert ich so ok also wir enden jetzt wir probieren jetzt ein paar sachen
aus weil aktuell haben wir ja nur eingestellt ping host ist ab host ist down das ist ja
nicht das was man eigentlich überprüfen will ok dann probieren wir doch mal ein bisschen
was advancederes und zwar ich habe hier in weißer voraussicht dass wir heute monitor
im zeug machen einen node exporter laufen auf meiner linux set up box also meinem linux
tv tuner und kann ich euch mal zeigen node exporter ist das ding von prometheus also
quasi der man könnte sagen sowas wie der agent nur von prometheus also vor einer anderen
monitoring lösung wobei es nicht wirklich wieder agent ist der agent kann ja auch aktiv
was ausführende exporter exportiert plus matrix so eins punkt zwei punkt eins zwei
neun was ist prometheus port neun neun neun null null eins oder so neun eins neun so etwas
slash matrix so und das bekommt man jetzt dort kann man auslesen guckt hier ganzes
zeug und wobei woran ich jetzt interessiert bin ist zum beispiel sda meine festplatten
belegung hier node file system available bites das interessiert mich das heißt darüber
also das ist was mich interessiert das ist der wert also irgendwie was auch immer ein
terabyte oder so ist irgendwie noch frei ungefähr also ja was auch immer das genau ist mal gucken
was google dazu sagt oder irgendwie hoch elf oder irgendwie so schreiben ne wie ging das
noch mal dass google das checkt ja das dürfte um das das dürften die also die bites sein
die auf meiner festplatte noch frei sind so und das hätte ich gerne in meinem zappig
drinnen würde ich jetzt prometheus verwenden ist das easy as fuck dieser eine fall dafür
die anderen schwerer und ich will jetzt mal ausprobieren ob der das hinbekommt weil angeblich
kann zappig mittlerweile prometheus sachen importieren und nicht nur angeblich ich habe
ein webcast drüber geguckt also ein tutorial von sammy slimani der hat erklärt wie man
das im zappig macht wo ist denn hier die was sind denn hier die host gibt es denn eigentlich
noch her vor real vor drei wochen fuck den gibt es immer noch den typ 1,5 millionen
tipp gibt es immer noch ok alles klar das war damals der größte als ich angefangen
war das glaube ich der größte deutsche youtuber gefolgt von simon desue oder der ist der hat
sie auch das hat ich auch erledigt das hätte ich nie gedacht dass mein video mein letztes
video mal so viele aufrufe hat wie herr tutorial oder fast mein letztes video hat fast fast
so viele so was wollte ich jetzt sagen danach kam simon desue der hat sich komplett erledigt
der typ der ist jetzt weiß ich ist da noch in dubai der hatte der hatte sein letztes
video was er hochgeladen hat war ja irgendwie hier das krasse leben in dubai oder so was
und dann kam irgendwelche scam sachen raus und dinger die er gedreht hat und seitdem
hat man nichts mehr von ihm gehört es gibt echt leute ältes man stimmt die außenseiter
gab es früher noch gibt sie noch ewig nichts mehr davon gehört dass das ist das ist die
gibt es nicht mehr oder gibt es hier noch sechs jahre ne die gibt es nicht mehr die
gibt es nicht mehr hat sich erledigt karlsson danke für den zapp ja eigene kanäle ok so
also jetzt mal was ordentliches mann also ich möchte jetzt dem ich möchte jetzt auf
meinem linux receiver checken wie viel festplatten platz noch frei ist also gehen wir mal hier
hin items aber wir können mal in die templates gucken ob es da was gibt um mit toys ne je
baited einfach nur prom also topics an der benahmung müssten wir noch mal arbeiten ich
ich hätte nach ich hätte im leben leben nicht nach prom warum warum bei prom niemand sucht
nach prom das war reiner zufall dass ich nach prom gesucht habe weil ich nach prome gesucht
habe sein sommer meiner prom da kommt doch keiner drauf alda ok was linux bei prometheus ok
was enden die da oder was ist so dies die ford zeug was sie hinzufügen oder oder not
exporter sie hätten es not exporter nennen sollen sie hätten es genau weiß jetzt not
exporter nennen sollen oder die folgt not exporter oder so so also was machen die hier
standardmäßig available memory cpu gest nice time nice cpu auslastung swap matrix interrupts
per second das braucht doch kein mensch load das interessiert mich tatsächlich ja maximum
number of open file descriptive ok das werde ich selbst machen weil ganz im ernst ich möchte
nicht für jedes diese ich will diese vielen metriken gar nicht haben ich will das einsammeln
was ich brauche und sonst nix das spart auch festplatten platz das spart performance und
was soll ich mit dem ganzen krempel ich meine manchmal ja ich kenne es von uns von der arbeit
manchmal ist das da ist es was anderes manchmal ist es cool wenn du noch mehr einsammelst weil
dir dann auffällt so nach dem motto aha guck mal da gehen die verbindungen hoch und zu
diesem zeitpunkt kann ich dann auch noch cpu auslastung gucken und ach gut dass ich jetzt
beispielsweise auch swap auslastung noch hab dann dann ist gut wenn du mehr sammelst aber
für meine linux kiste daheim man kann die deaktivieren also das heißt ich kann das
template applyen und die dann deaktivieren wäre es nicht sinnvoller ich mache mir ein
eigenes template und dann mache ich da nur das rein was ich haben will wobei wie machen
die das überhaupt sabbix wir fragen das mal selbst ab ich will einfach mal gucken wie
man das einrichtet prometheus checks two steps are required ein htp master item pointing
to data endpoint ok konfigure host create items htp master nie htp alda man kann es
auch maximal kompliziert machen ok also host items wobei ne ne ne hier dafür dafür items
reate item also item warum heißt das eigentlich item warum haben die das nicht einfach check
genannt beim nagios heißt der kram check und ich finde ein check ist irgendwie tausendmal
aussagekräftiger von namen her als item item ist sowas wie item temp entity blub so das
sind so so random namen wo keiner wirklich was damit objekt wo keiner wirklich was mit
anfangen kann ok great item sowas müssen wir machen wir brauchen ein htp master agent
die item sind vom typ check feifett ok sabbix agent simple check htp h ok name node exporter
master oder so key node exporter master bin mir nicht sicher warum man das unterschiedlich
benennen sollte ach so name ist was angezeigt wird und das andere ist was der benutzt das
ist schon ok das darf ruhig so heißen dann brauchen wir die hier die matrix pass und
jetzt was durch htp davor schreiben pass ok nice pass leute massive parsing passiert
nichts warum hast du keinen sabbix agent drauf weil das eine linux tv tuner set top box ist
für die gibt es kein sabbix agent wobei leute ich habe noch nicht gesucht danach opkg list
sabbix ne gibt es nicht aber es gibt ein statisches arm binary node exporter was funktioniert
das ist ein das ist ein ganz normales arm v7 ding von 2000 irgendwas arm v7 v3 was auch
immer dafür gibt es bestimmt einen sabbix agent aber ich bin mir nicht sicher ob es
ein sabbix agent gibt der dann auch darauf läuft mit den libraries versionen die dort
drauf sind es gibt wohl einen neuen sabbix agent in go also den da hier ich habe ich
habe ich habe schon mal einen drauf kopiert aber da habe ich auch nichts gefunden was
tut und der node exporter ging direkt deswegen und ich wollte immer ausprobieren ist es
mit prometheus im sabbix ok also das muss man query fields blablabla request type seconds
timeout drei sekunden alles gut raw data wahrscheinlich eddas brauchen wir nicht body ich lasse das
einfach mal alles standard authentication brauchen wir nicht post interface ja für
die ip update intervall fünf sekunden glaube es geht los eine minute ich war doch nicht
eine minute das muss das muss hier schlage auf schlag gehen so und das habe ich in einem
tutorial video gesehen dass man bei dem item sagen muss du not keep history weil das das
item das master item ruft ja standardmäßig diesen ganzen shit aus und würdest du die
datenbank schreiben hast du eigentlich ein face reveal gemacht nie offiziell ne fünf
ist wild ich lasse mal fünf ich meine ich habe nur ein haustrainer das aktuell abfragt
es sollte der sollte der verkraften so fünf sekunden und das war es jetzt was der item
ok schauen wir mal test ob man kann es testen pock get value and test string was value of
type string ist not suitable for value numeric das klingt logisch wo trägt man das ein da
oben text und jetzt fest aha ok das abrufen funktioniert schon mal in meinen unboxing
video ja weil ich so oft irgendwas an boxe ja ok alles klar wunderbar haben wir geschafft
latest data sehe ich jetzt ja wahrscheinlich nix latest data weil mein alles teilweise
schon hardcore unübersichtlich weil ich speichern nix in der history also sehe ich ja auch kein
latest data ok dann machen wir mal weiter naja es ist was du für sachen träumst in
der regel ist es ein schlechtes zeichen wenn man nicht mehr zwischen traum und realität
unterscheiden kann wobei es wahrscheinlich aktuell sogar besser ist passiert so viel
beschissenes zeug vielleicht ist es gar nicht schlimm wenn man das nicht mal so ganz also
so das will man das will ich jetzt aber noch machen items create item so was müssen wir
denn jetzt machen um dort einen prometheus check prometheus pattern was jetzt bin ich
über vorne was soll ich machen prometheus gibt es das hier dependent item stand da stand
also was dependent item und dann wähle ich jetzt den master check da aus master item
node export ok das ist ja maximal kompliziert gemacht aber gut ich meine das ist halt sehr
flexibel du kannst mehr oder weniger alles damit rumwursten wie das brauchst aber das
ist gar nicht so weit von der realität weg ich weiß nicht was ich hier mache units ja
bites oder key ok also das ding ist disk pre nenne ich das jetzt einfach mal so vielleicht
sollte ich das noch prefixen dass ich weiß dass es vom node exporter kommt node exporter
disk 3 heißt das jetzt so und wie bekomme ich da jetzt daten rein ich muss auf pre processing
und dann prometheus pattern das ist das ist next level shit hier prometheus pattern und
dann diesen krempel hier rein oder wie str was hatte ich gesagt ich will free bites leute
was ist in der unterschied zwischen free bites und available bites warum ist free bites und
available bites unterschiedlich sollte das nicht das gleiche sein hat da irgendwie einer
eine feinfertige erklärung für
i-nodes aber beiden stehen bereits also weiß ich auch bei ihnen für i-nodes was eigenes
hat matrix vom filesystem exporter kriegen wir das da explained ok free available which
ist how many bites are free das ist ja gut dass free einfach available ist und was ist
free ignoring reserved blocks ok also ich will available haben in dem fall das ist das ist
ja wirklich mal feiner kram soll das heißt ich kopiere mir das jetzt ok also wenn ich
das jetzt richtig verstanden alles gehen wir dahin kopieren das da rein dass er von da
die werte abfragen soll dann sage ich value was es ja irgendwie auch ist was custom und
fail keine ahnung numerik numerik anscheinend naja numerik float würde ich sagen wobei
nie es ist in bites es ist anscheinend es ist anscheinend es gibt keine halben bites
das ist in bites das ist ok so ich hoffe mal das klappt jetzt beim monitoring latest data
für den er klappt natürlich nicht geil last check warum hat er nicht gecheckt was ist
hier los er hat kein check gemacht an er checkt wahrscheinlich bloß einmal die minute wobei
den er sollte alle fünf sekunden checken nur nur nur zum testen ich sag dir mal dass
er das für einen tag speichern soll das kann ich danach wieder löschen dass ich sehe ob
es latest data gibt latest data plus aha das was kaputt guck du mal das was broken value
of type string is not suitable for wie jetzt der kann diese prometheis scientific schreibweise
nicht in numerik umwandeln das aber ziemlich beschissen weil die meisten values von prometheis
sehen so aus das ist ziemlich ziemlicher sack ok da suchen wir jetzt mal danach excellent
ok vielleicht vielleicht das da nicht da gibt es bestimmt leute schon das ähnliche problem
list sefs nein zabex zabex muss ich noch dabei schreiben items with scientific notation values
korrekt so ein item habe ich an sein genau die fehlermeldung bekomme ich auch alles klar
try a simple trick numeric an sein kasse multiplier wort ernsthaft was sind das für komische
hacks um das rein zu kriegen schon dass das das gefällt mir schon mal nicht ok wir bekommen
daten also muss irgendwelche was zum was haben sie sich denn dabei wieder gedacht also was
jetzt preprocessing und dann was was was soll ich machen custom multiplier multiplier
das ding heißt so kasse multiplier ich mache das jetzt einfach mal obvius leute oder also
wer cringe wer das nicht weiß dass das so geht latest data ok da noch nicht gecheckt
ist immer noch so aber ich glaube easy na muss man muss man wissen macht er hier irgendwie
nur alle minute ok die bedienung ist noch ein bisschen ein bisschen anstrengend für
mich ja ach jetzt geht's jetzt geht's leute guck mal jetzt funktioniert jetzt bekommen
wir alle fünf sekunden update über den festplatten verbrauch ok das lässt sich jetzt ja relativ
easy testen ok letzten fünf minuten so alles klar letzten fünf minuten wir machen jetzt
einfach die festplatte ein bisschen voll auf der kiste und gucken mal was passiert
dd interface def 0 o f lub punkt ach so moment moment hahaha mnt wir müssen wir müssen nicht
ich möchte nicht den internen flaschspeicher voll machen cute chat so dd interfacing block
size 4096 count obei nee wir machen einfach 1024 und sagen ja halb da richtig abverzweiflicht
und sagen kaut wobei wir könnten auch count 1 sagen und dann block size egal kaum so also
ein kilobyte kann ich hier einfach so was machen geht das nicht kaum doch und wie groß
ist es jetzt was er geschrieben hat ein mb hat er jetzt geschrieben ok so zehn mb das
sind zehn mb zehn mb 100 mb das sollte auch relativ schnell gehen ok gigabyte vier sehe
ich das jetzt richtig leute vier vier gigabyte oder so das müssten jetzt ok zwei gigabyte
zwei gigabyte feil und jetzt status nee status oh gott ah leute dd progress ist es progress
dd progress da gibt es auch so ein komisches progress status gleich progress das ist zu
alt das dd na gut dann sind wir mal 5 hat ich bin mir nicht sicher ob sie dafür überhaupt
gibt ok wir sollten jetzt eigentlich updates bekommen dass der dis naja naja man wie habe
ich eingestellt wie oft wird mein interface aktualisiert leute was habe ich eingestellt
user settings profile refresh alle alle fünf sekunden man bärm latest data plus aber ist
schon fertig ok aktualisiert er hier eigentlich gerade ja er aktualisiert ich habe es gerade
gefreschen sehen ok plupp plupp zwei ja guck mal guck mal es funktioniert wir kriegen jetzt
mit wenn wenn der speicherplatz runter geht ok nice das ist schick ich meine nicht dass
man so zuguckt aber das ist schön dass man in der history zugucken kann wie wo wann da
was hingekommen ist also ist gut ok also sagen wir mal so wir können auch ohne probleme
10 gigabyte machen kann man dd irgendwie drosseln fällt mir jetzt nichts zu ein dd limit geht
das dd kann gelimitet werden ich meine ich kann es durch irgendwas durchpipen was es
limitiert aber ich weiß nicht ob dd das selber kann ja gut klar also dass man es durch pv
und sowas das ist mir auch klar aber ich weiß nicht ob dd erst und ja das kenne ich auch
ich dachte was i own was für ein ding ach i own nice nicht ion ich habe ein eis oder
sowas gelesen i own nice ok das ergibt natürlich sinn habe ich das da überhaupt drauf theoretisch
schon ja wie funktioniert in der kram ok pit ja moment das ist aber doch eher wenn es mehrere
programme gibt damit kann man doch nicht jetzt gezielt sagen maximal 10 mb oder das ist quasi
wenn ich mehrere sachen laufen habe dass ich was runter priorisieren kann naja wurscht ich
meine so geht es auch und das das reicht ja hier um zuzugucken dass es runter geht aber
das ist na warum ist das ah leute guckt mal das ist gut wisst ihr warum das wieder hoch
gegangen ist weil ich in die gleiche datei reinschreibe wie vorher das ist das mit die
datei quasi verschwunden die alte und jetzt schreibt er die neue rein einfach schlechtere
festplatten kaufen massive idee einfach die festplatten langsamer machen big brain time
aber gut das finde ich sehr cool und jetzt könnte man natürlich noch ein trigger setzen
wenn die festplatte unter 8 948 gigabyte geht dann soll soll es alerten wir gucken wir
ob die das mache ich gleich das mache ich gleich weil das weiß ich nicht wie man die
wie man da trigger einstellt trigger habe ich glaube ich so noch nicht angelegt das
muss mir mal anschauen ok also er geht auf jeden fall unter 98 erst mal warning ja gut
wenn ich wenn ich er aus anlegen kann kann ich auch warnings anlegen ok hören wir mal
auf club 2 das ganze mal wieder löschen und jetzt sollte es gleich hochgehen ja da ist
gelöscht gut ok wie legt man dort dann jetzt an dass ich eine benachrichtigung nicht benachrichtigung
wie lege ich jetzt dann an dass er mir überhaupt trigger sind das dass er mir überhaupt anzeigt
achtung es gibt ein problem weil festplattenplatz geht zur neige wie macht man das create trigger
name habe ich das andere genannt nodexporter nodexporter disk disk 3 aber wie nennt man
den kram denn wie benennen die die anderen denn zeigt mal hier unavailable ok die schreiben
da was sind sinnvolles rein tatsächlich create trigger ja disk usage oder so oder ja disk
usage ich schreibe alles klein disk usage können wir das ding nennen so und wie sage
ich dem jetzt dass der gefällig checken soll dass nodexporter disk 3 probleme hat
und expression last ok item erst mal auswählen was ich haben will disk free so ach du scheiße
last ok das passt doch most recent value kleiner kann ich jetzt sowas machen wie wie 1000 gigabyte
geht das wait a minute wenn das funktioniert dann müsste ich aber sagen big big brains
habe ich aber das wird wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren das muss ich wahrscheinlich
schon in bites angeben oder moment not not classified ja sekunde das ist ein ein ein
disaster alter hui hui hui warning warning update ok und latest latest data
die nicht latest data problems oder haus ok der hat keine problems aktuell das juckt dir
nicht das habe ich schon mal nicht richtig gemacht so funktioniert das net gibt es irgendwie
eine möglichkeit dass das irgendwie zu testen ich meine woher soll ich wissen dass die ob
diese expressions da jetzt richtig sind oder nicht muss ich mir jetzt wirklich das in bites
raussuchen ernsthaft muss ich jetzt wirklich sagen latest data das da und dann ja ok noch
mal add am moment leute ich hätte einfach warten müssen das funktioniert es funktioniert
alles ok kommando zurück kommando zurück alles gut check funktioniert warning problem
excuse ich ach deswegen plantet man da operational data eine gibt kein operational data ja geil
dankeschön es habe ich es exzellent da weiß man da weiß man bescheid ja ok das das finde
ich ja schon ein bisschen eklig dass das dass es so angezeigt wird ich meine das ist woher
soll ich jetzt wissen dass das 950 mb sind oder erkennt ihr das so aus dem kopf vielleicht
muss ich das in den preprozessor für die für das für das prometos einlesen nach
ein speicher in prozent ja das ist auch eine gute idee in prozent in dem popup steht nichts
drin in dem popup steht plus das gleiche hier drin wie das da also nix nix interessantes
ok also prinzipiell funktioniert und witzigerweise checkt das auch hier drin guck mal hier kapiert
hat er das hier habe ich unter 1000 g hat er das kapiert aber bei der anzeige dann nicht
jetzt gucken wir mal ob das überhaupt stimmt was ich da gemacht habe kleiner 945 gigabyte
ist es jetzt ja nicht mehr jetzt ist es nämlich wieder available ok df df zeigt mal wieder
bullshit an was jetzt oder habe ich mich hier vorhin verguckt disk usage ne ok da checkt
die schwellwerte der kapiert die schwellwerte ist gut ja er hat noch nicht aktuell die schwellwerte
noch nicht aktualisiert weil eigentlich sollte es eigentlich sollte es bei 945 sein mittlerweile
ich glaube der hat einfach noch nicht aktualisiert ne bei prometos nicht der exportiert die bytes
das muss man im frontend machen und der checkt das hier auch mit g aber da zeigt das dummerweise
in gigabyte in bytes an bei problem das natürlich ziemlich 3 3 headache übrigens ich habe den
check jetzt angepasst kleiner 945 warum hat sich das noch nicht aktualisiert ich hätte
jetzt eigentlich erwartet dass ich das und dass ich das der craft auch aktualisiert warum
aktualisiert sich das net ich meine ich habe die ich habe die regeln angepasst was ist
da los ich meine ich werde es ja wohl kaum erst löschen müssen oder dass es funktioniert
da steht es richtig aber sonst interessiert ihn das nicht ok ich lösche das mal ich glaube
vielleicht habe ich was verkehrt gemacht ok jetzt ist weg und jetzt sind auch die probleme
weg aber muss das man muss das doch im nachhinein anpassen können das wäre wahrscheinlich
muss ich einfach nur ein bisschen warten wie habe ich das genannt nodexporter disk 3 und
jetzt hier die expression rein last 945 ok event closes all problems das wird schon passen
so wahrscheinlich geht es deswegen nicht weil die expression anders war keine ahnung wie
auch immer ok ad ane not classified warning update mir angucken und wahrscheinlich daheim
verwenden warum ist es jetzt wieder auf 1000 alter willst mich rollen oder was was mit
dem ding los update der die crafts irgendwie super langsam nur oder oder was was ist halt
er denn das habe ich früher mal in da kiosk verwenden da war es auch schon pains champ
ich glaube das ist einfach krepp ja das ist doch so ein blöder spruch den ich früher
mit fabian immer benutzt wahrscheinlich dauert das obs dauernd das eins ist auch wieder warning
da oder was alter was ist das das soll kein warning da sein das soll kein warning da sein
das ergibt überhaupt keinen sinn dass dann warning ist geh mal in den trigger sekunde
hier da disk 3 kuckierda latest unter 945 und es ist aktuell eindeutig nicht bei den
2000 lösch mal die expression ich habe den ganz ich habe den den den ganzen trigger eben
schon gelöscht und neu hinzugefügt wenn ich die expression lösche dann ist es weg
kann ich kann ich empty sein ja ok keine ahnung haben wir was ganz was anderes ein so
beim jetzt steht es auf unter 95 und er ist der meinung hä wait was hat er für schmerzen
bitteschön 145 runde der das auf runde der das irgendwie oder oder oder was ok ich gebe
die bals an ich ich gebe die bals an so und da null null null aber das kann nicht sein
dass man das so angehen muss das ja fehler anfällig ist fack das funktioniert ok wenn
man die bals angibt funktioniert jetzt testen wir mal was anderes jetzt schiebe jetzt schiebe
den wir ihn jetzt wird er richtig und die berget 940 g hatte ich vorgemacht aber mb
Nö, nop, nop, ist ihm egal.
Sind's vielleicht gibt, ach das kann tatsächlich sein.
Das, das, das, das, du hast recht, das kann sein.
Dann machen wir das mal so, vielleicht, vielleicht muss man sowas machen.
Okay, Zabbix, ähm, ähm, ja was such ich denn?
G, B, G, Unit Symbols.
Gibt's jetzt auch nicht wirklich Sinn, oder?
Okay, also, also, dann rechnen wir 940, G, B, G, B, G, B, G, B, G, B, G, B.
Okay, 800, 875 muss ich da rechnen, 800.
Okay, schauen wir mal, schauen wir mal.
kann man kann man gibt schreiben check des sammichs wahrscheinlich nicht muss man muss
man von hand umrechnen weil pepega
10 ulti ich habe keine ahnung wenn ich ehrlich bin ja ok alles gut dass das klappt
nee aber guckt mal leute last value 953 und ich sage 945 g
das ergibt keinen sinn ok dann kommt wisst ihr was wir schreiben jetzt die
bites rein weil mit bites funktioniert aber da muss ich mal gucken wie man das ordentlicher
machen kann ok wunderbar so also zumindest sollte man jetzt ja das ist ziemlich pepega
was lehrzeichen dazwischen nee es muss schon hinten dran wenn ich ein lehrzeichen dazwischen
macht sagt er wahrscheinlich dass es nicht geht und sagt er hier expression oder so ok gut also
jetzt haben wir das eingerichtet und theoretisch wenn alles funktioniert dann sollte das ist
übrigens an kraft auch schöner dass kraft ran zoomt wenn es bei keinen null gibt vielleicht
mache ich mir noch zusätzlichen grafana und exportieren an den sammichs graben
ok und jetzt und jetzt lassen wir ihn mal hier schreiben dd und er sollte jetzt eigentlich
mitbekommen ja auch bei problems gleich er sollte es gleich mitbekommen wenn der graben
ach jetzt macht das jetzt checkt das oder jetzt zoomt daran aber normal so um da nicht
ran ah obvius so er sollte irgendwann demnächst unter 945 fallen und wenn er unter 945 fällt
was genau macht das ding der kraft da gerade gibt das heizungs dashboard noch ja aber das
hat keine daten mehr so sobald das jetzt gleich fällt unter 945 was ja bald der fall ist dann
sollte es einen alarm auslösen sowohl im dashboard sollte es dann anzeigen hier achtung
warning hier sollte den alert auftauchen und hier sollte vielleicht auch was passieren
latest data woops wollte ich gar nicht warum ist jetzt eigentlich der trigger nicht mal
angezeigt der trigger müsste hier sein ach denn der ist der ist rausgezoomt der trigger
so auf gib ihm komm vor geht das langsam ich hätte den trigger höher höher machen
soll oder jetzt ist es auch noch fertig ok nächstes feil auf volle pulle das lustige
ist der daraus könnte man sich jetzt sogar ungefähr ausrechnen wie schnell die festplatte
schreibt weil wir haben wir keinen progress anzeige 88,1 mb die sekunde ok die ssd ist
auch nicht das was sie was sie mal war da ist der trigger guck da ist die trigger schwelle
und hat er jetzt was ausgelöst ah guck mal jetzt gibt es auch ein warning note exporter
disk free auf diesem host und ansonsten hat das hier aktualisiert glaube ich langsamer
da sollte jetzt warning drin stehen ja das refreshed soll jetzt ok jetzt steht ein warning
drin das ist das finde ich ach guck mal hier unten hat sich jetzt auch aktualisiert muss
alles auf zehn sekunden runter das ist natürlich schon eine coole übersicht da siehst du sofort
wenn was wenn was im arsch ist der host ist noch ab so ist es nicht aber da ist gerade
die festplatte am volllaufen das ist eigentlich echt nice ja also wisst ihr so die optimale
kombination wäre wenn die nicht ihre komischen rwd crafts hätten sondern sowas so coole
crafts wie grafana das wäre echt die optimale kombi weil die grafana crafts sind schon deutlich
hübscher und auch angenehmer zu bedienen als der kram ich meine man könnte eine grafana
installieren leute was haltet ihr von der von der ist die idee 5 hat oder 3 hat man
könnte grafana installieren und per i frame im dashboard hier anzeigen guckt mal zum
beispiel grafana guck mal hier das ist mein heizungs dashboard ne heizungs dashboard
er hat keine datengrad aber ok machen wir mal privacy so hier heizungs dashboard heizungs
dashboard könne ich nicht dann kannst du den subx auch sparen wenn überall exporter
nutzt ich nutze überall exporter ich nutze auch slmp und ich benutze bestimmt auch den
subx agent so guck mal jetzt könnte man hier doch sagen ob das funktioniert edit widget
site iframe nama add
ok subx grafana hat probleme in dem iframe wie es aussieht
da kannst du auch überall ne ne ne ne also subx ist schon cool was halt so dieses klassische
up down wir pingen was wir gucken mal port auf und zu ist monitoring angeht ich mein guck
mal so einfache sachen dynamic item keiner ich glaube man muss hier irgendwas export
das wird es prinzipiell funktionen also zum beispiel wenn du im grafana so was einfaches
checken willst wie http port also keine ahnung port 80 offen und response enthält blub da
musst du den host hinzufügen dann musst du dir irgendwie den node einen blackbox exporter
draufhauen dann musst du gucken dass die rewrite im blackbox exporter stimmen da musst du den
blackbox exporter config anpassen im zweifelsfall die ssl configs darin machen dass es funktioniert
gehen tut das aber für solche checks von außen ist es habe ich schon cooler weil er
halt dafür gemacht ist für für node exporter einsammeln und anwendungsmetrien ist ganz
klar die prometors grafana kombi besser wenn man jetzt natürlich noch ich mein warum eigentlich
kein grafana graf im im zappix einbinden wo ist das problem ja kann man eigentlich machen
ich meine grafana ist ziemlich leichtgewichtig kann man auch zusätzlich draufkloppen dann
ist gut und ich sehe ich bin fast vier stunden und wir machen den schluss an der stelle ich
werde jetzt pepo fett was essen ssh hi fahr den pie mal kurz runter nicht überarbeiten
korrekt geht es nachher weiter vielleicht vielleicht vielleicht komme ich heute abend
noch mal an aber dann werden wir nicht zappix weiter bauen sondern einschlafen stream machen
oder so also einschlafen im prinzip gegen kein verlauf wachen stream ich habe mir irgendwann
mal sogar so einen poe hat gekauft habe ich noch nie verwendet übrigens ich kann euch
ich kann euch was empfehlen habe ich bei mache ich jetzt mal schnell habe ich bei meinen
exis points gemerkt und zwar wenn man keinen switch router was auch immer hat der modernes
poe kann also nicht dieses uralt af poe sonst was also da wo auch ein bisschen bisschen
leistung durch die leidung kommt habe ich folgendes entdeckt und zwar wenn man bei amazon guckt
nur mal so das was der scheiß kostet wenn man da sucht nach poe injector genau att mein
ich soll wenn er dann 802 att sucht da findest du dinger teilweise aus ist billiger geworden
ich habe nichts gesagt da findest du da findest du teilweise mega teure sachen so was hier
74 euro sonst was und ich habe festgestellt oder so was ich habe festgestellt die billigste
variante ist tatsächlich ein unify poe injector unify 48 poe nein nicht der poe poe 48 ja
der kostet nämlich nur 13 euro und ist ein ganz normaler das schreiben die zwar nicht
und ist ein ganz normaler 802 punkt irgendwas att kompatibler poe injector und da habe ich
auch meinen aktuellen exis point dran und ich habe kein unify exis point da dran das
ist die billigste die billigste variante die ich gefunden habe für 13 euro einen ordentlichen
poe injector zu finden natürlich ist ihnen ihre hoffnung du kaufst die unify exis points
und die schreiben jetzt auch nicht drauf ja das ist ein ganz normaler 802 irgendein poe
injector ist es aber kann kraftaner zabex nicht nicht einbinden doch das geht es gibt
einen kraftaner exporter oder man kann data source in kraftaner zabex verwenden das funktioniert
doch doch dat funst so jetzt gehe ich aber auf jetzt wollte ich euch mal zeigen 13 euro
und ordentlichen poe injector kriegst du sonst auch nicht also ein der das neueste kann sonst
auch nicht also wir sehen uns im nächsten streben leute bis denn macht's gut zu